Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wirrungsstellen machen
So jetzt jetzt so ist gut
G1 war okay, G2 war nichts und G2 haben wir das gestern oder vorgestern gesehen das sagt wieso okay, wieso habe ich
auch noch Pains Champing in Erinnerung
Massive Pains Champing Kampfkäffchen Dankeschön drei Monate Subscription und der Turbo 3400
poggers alter
Massive Subs
Keckweight Moment Moment Moment Moment Sekunde
So also sehe ich das richtig ihr macht in eurer Abschlussprüfung macht ihr um L
Diagramme jetzt ernsthaft wirklich
Das ist ja
Aber da kann ich dir nicht helfen ich kann das selber nicht gut
Kann die wieso Abschlussprüfung schicken ja ich kann die ja nicht zeigen das ist ja das problem
Moment warum konntest du eine Abschlussprüfung mit heimnehmen okay was auch immer ich kann dir hier ich kann dir ja nicht nicht zeigen
Weil da immer noch Copyright drauf ist ich verstehe nicht warum eine Prüfung eine Prüfung Copyright ist so dass man sich nicht
Ach das ist fehl das ganze ist das ganze Ausbildungssystem mit der Erkauung das ist so ein Rotz
Egal was willst du machen
Programmieren gestrichen ja wisse
Ich nicht ich habe das gemachten strukturierte Verkabelung gestrichen wieso hat so ein Punkt auf der Maske
Das ist weil es ein logo ist kommt mal wenn du es groß machst erkennst du es das ist ein logo
Omas Drogen hat subscribt
Toller Name für den drei drei Monate ich habe es nicht verstanden
für den drei drei Monate
Ach easy
Ich sage euch jetzt mal wie es ist leute ob ihr die Prüfung besteht mit einer 1 oder mit einer 4 minus
Das ist egal
Hauptsache ihr habt es bestanden
Da kräht kein Hahn mehr danach der einzige Fall
Wo es eventuell sein könnte theoretisch dass sich noch irgendwie mal irgendjemand für eure Abschlussprüfer interessiert ist
solltet ihr direkt instant nach der Ausbildung die stelle wechseln und das noch nicht sicher haben und noch versuche oder so aber
Aber selbst da
Warnet also mich hat noch niemals jemand nach meiner Abschlussprüfung gefragt
Und ich habe es ehrlich gesagt auch noch von niemand anderem gehört dass er jemals in seiner Abschlussprüfung gefragt wurde
Habt ihr eure Abschluss habt ihr euer Abschlusszeugnis überhaupt abgeholt
Also ich habe mir ich habe in der Berufsschule das liegt immer noch da
Also also mein mein mein Berufsschulzeugnis mein letztes Berufsschulzeugnis liegt immer noch in der Abschlussprüfung
Und mein letztes Berufsschulzeugnis liegt immer noch in der Berufsschule wobei ich glaube mittlerweile nicht nach zehn Jahren dürfen die es ja wegschmeißen oder
Ist das nach zehn Jahren dürfen die das entsorgen oder
Kopfbundhiller Dankeschön drei Monate Subscription
Ist ja schon länger als zehn Jahre her
Kommt das denn in das Archiv keine Ahnung ich müsste da mal anrufen und fragen ob ich meine mein
Zeugnis abholen kann und da fragen sie ja welcher welcher welcher
Welcher Ausbildungsjahrgang waren sie dann sag ich 2007
Da muss ich erst mal in Keller gucken wo das noch ist
Ich versuche nicht mein Abschlusszeugnis ich habe eh eins ich habe nur eins und zwei
und ich war nicht
Irgendwie sonderlich schlau oder so in der Berufsschule und ich war auch nicht sonderlich
Irgendwie streber mäßig oder voll engagiert in der Berufsschule die Berufsschule war einfach so easy
Und ich habe auch nicht so viel mit dem Berufsschulzeugnis
Und ich war auch nicht sonderlich irgendwie streber mäßig oder voll engagiert in der Berufsschule die Berufsschule war einfach so easy
Und trotzdem haben es leute geschafft habe ich euch ja letztens in dem einen video erzählt trotzdem haben es leute geschafft 16 zu schreiben
Als sie zweimal create table geschrieben haben
Habt ihr übrigens schon gelesen die games kommen 2021
Die wird wieder online sein also im prinzip genau das gleiche wie letztes jahr wo schon keine sau interessiert hat
Ich kann sich kann sich noch irgendjemand an die games kommen 2020 erinnern ich weiß die hatten irgendso einen komischen
Stream mit irgendso einem halbwegs bekannten moderator
Und
Das habe ich nicht geguckt das ging mir voll am arsch vorbei und
Im prinzip geht mir das immer noch am arsch vorbei was die da machen
Ja guck mal jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft jetzt mal ernsthaft
Die meisten leute die auf die games kommen fahren haben nicht die möglichkeit was zu spielen
Die an also die wartezeiten da sind immer kurz die musik aus man braucht ein bisschen was entspannteres die wartezeiten dort das ist
Das ist absolut lächerlich die wartezeit auf der games kommen also das schlimmste was ich gesehen habe auf der games kommen das war 2000
Wann war ich das letzte mal auf der games kommen 2016 oder so
Also ich hatte auf der games kommen prinzipiell glück ich habe die sachen immer im vorfeld organisiert und hat mir schon termine gemacht und hat mir
Also passende sachen besorgt und so also sprich ich musste dann meistens gar nicht so lange warten aber wenn ich mir jetzt überlege
Ich wäre auf die games kommen gefahren einfach so als als aber als normaler
Zuschauer schrägstrich besucher der da hingeht sich bei einem stand anmeldet und dann drei stunden wartet
Bis er dran kommt wir waren ich kann mich noch daran erinnern wir waren in dem einen jahr beim nvidia stand wo es vr gab
Die hatten da die hatten da ich weiß nicht welches headset das war irgend so neues vor er hat sagt da gab es dann die demo
Da gab es dann die portal genau da gab es die portal demo und und diese unterwasser demo
Wo
Genau das da
Also die die ne ne das nicht nein
Die da war das
Genau also die die demo haben wir dann da gemacht wo man wo man
Roboter repären musste in vr und wurde dann am ende am ende gab es und leicht
monke es moment bei dieser demo passt mal auf
Moment der boden ist doch unter einem weggefallen in der demo
Okay, dann ist es noch ein bisschen andere demo also ich habe eine portal ich habe eine portal vr demo gespielt
Wo einem am ende an der boden unter den füßen weggefallen ist
Das war ein bisschen monke es aber das war okay zumindest worauf ich jetzt eigentlich raus wollte ist folgendes
wir hatten einen termin bei nvidia das heißt wir wir
Konnten quasi uns im vorfeld also haben uns im vorfall schon angemeldet
Und ich kann mir da echt schlecht vor mein andere fanden das ultra gar nicht so gut
Echt schlecht vor mein andere fanden das ultra geil könnte ich mir vorstellen aber es war an dem tag schon eine riesen schlange bei nvidia
Die ging schon einmal quasi um den kompletten stand rum und da sind wir hin an die an die an den eingang vom
Vom stand haben da unsere nvidia kärtchen gezeigt haben gesagt ja
Wir hatten einen termin ausgemacht und da haben die ernsthaft den fehl im felix da
Ich glaube schon ich glaube ich er mit dem felix genau
Da haben wir uns ernsthaft
zu zweit
an der kompletten schlange der leute vorbeigeführt und uns an die erste position gestellt
Und da habe ich dann dargestanden keck weight wir sind gerade irgendwie an keine ahnung 80 leuten vorbeigelaufen die finden das bestimmt jetzt nicht
So geil näher zumindest
Das wird das ganze wurde ja dann auch schlimmer
Als wir dann irgendwie zwei tage später mittags noch mal vorbeigelaufen sind die hatten wirklich also
Normalerweise hast du ja ein paar solche bei den games kommen ständen hast du immer so abstandsmarker so quasi hier eine halbe stunde hier eine stunde
Und die konnten das überhaupt nicht mehr
Du hast die du hast die fiziprüfung geschrieben nice und
Wie lief es erzählt krelak 17 monat dankeschön für den zapp
Stream da und einer hier ist nix dauernd so das wollte ich sagen und die
Schlange am zweiten tag bei dem nvidia vr stand
Die ging jetzt ist ohne scheiß drei mal
ging das ding
Um den nvidia stand rum du musstest glaube ich frag mich nicht zweieinhalb stunden warten um eine vr demo spielen zu können
Das war die unterwasser demo und das war eine portal demo du musstest zweieinhalb stunden warten dass du glaube ich danach
am ende was war das drei minuten oder so
Spielen konntest also was ist spielen die drei minuten vor er beriesen beriesen lassen konntest hallo
zweieinhalb stunden oder noch länger warten
alter also die games kommen sagt einfach nur noch und man hat jetzt in corona zeiten gesehen dass
So messen sind total useless eigentlich braucht keiner
Also erst in den corona zeiten wird viel mehr verkauft und so messen brauchst du gar nicht
So zeigt man ja was ghr 1 war mir ghr 2 war also eben habe ich es genau umgedreht gehört ghr 1 war nice ghr 2 war war nicht gut
aber
Ja gut es stimmt ich weiß nicht ob ihr die gleichen prüfungen hat
Habt aber wenn ihr am gleichen tag hat sind das eigentlich deutschlandweit die gleichen prüfungen was ist das ist das ist alles
Die gleichen prüfungen was ist das ist wirtschafts was ist was steht denn wieso eigentlich wirtschaft sozial
Wirtschaft sozial kunde oder irgendwie sowas
Ich weiß es gar nicht wirtschaft und soziales wirtschaft und sozial kunde
Ja, dann hat sich gelohnt also wie lange musstest du warten so okay zeigt mal her was gab es denn für fragen was gab es für fragen
heute abschließungen
Ich sagte ghr sagst du für hypersubscription 17 monate
Ghr 1 rate 6 fragen was haben die gefragt zu rate 6 rate 6 ist tatsächlich ein bisschen trickreich weil in rate 6 ist in rate 5 mit
Zwei paritätsplannen also wenn man da wenn man da zeigen soll wie das wie das x-or gemapt wird das ist gar nicht so
intuitiv
Struktur struktur kramme
Struktur kramme die haben nicht ernsthaft im jahr 2021 noch nach struktur kramme gefragt oder
Ghr 1 routine tabelle rate 6 auf zeichnen okay dann muss man das doch mal berechnen mit netto kapazität also wenn ich das
Richtig in erinnerung habe ist es doch so bei einem rate 6 verlierst du zwei festplatten
Bei einem rate 5 verlierst du eine platte von der kapazität her und bei einem rate 6 verlierst du zwei platten von der kapazität her
Also wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe ist es doch so bei einem rate 6 verlierst du zwei festplatten
von der kapazität her bei einem rate 6 verlierst du zwei platten von der kapazität her dafür hast du bei einem rate 6
halt also was bei einem rate 6 halt richtig was bringt ist du hast relativ schnell ein read gerade in der heutigen zeit da ist ja so ein x-or nix
Du kannst ja da von vielen platten gleichzeitig lesen also hast einen schnell read aber du hast einen normalen ride speed wenn ich das jetzt so bei rate 6 noch im
im hinterkopf habe und halbwegs normalen ride speed vielleicht einen ticken schneller ich verwende nur rate 69 gibt es gibt gibt es
Leute die rate 420 verwenden das würde jetzt tatsächlich funktionieren
ich kann aber rate sogar dran achja ja gut also also meiner meiner ihr könnt mir mal sagen ob sich die irk damit zufrieden gibt
also aus meiner sicht sind die vorteile von rate 6 gegenüber rate 5 du kannst also du brauchst eine platte mehr es kann aber auch eine platte mehr ausfallen
die lesegeschwindigkeit ist ein bisschen schneller ja das muss ein ausfallsicherer das ist eigentlich die hauptsächliche vorteil gegenüber rate 5
die fragen halt auch so was für ticket system spricht was für ach du große scheiße ganz einfach first level einfach nie machen
achso ja das nur 2 statt 1 ja das reicht was ist rate kennst du es nicht das ist doch überall in der werbung
du musst auf youtube auf twitch überall
also was nein was mit rate gemeint ist ist wenn du komm hör auf oh ne wie er lässt sich nicht jebaiten was ist da los also mit rate ist gemeint dass du
mehrere platten zusammenfasst zu einer logischen platte mit mit also mit unterschiedlichen zielen ja also du kannst sagen hey ich will dass es möglichst ausfallsicher ist
du willst kannst sagen hey ich fasse das so zusammen dass es möglichst schnell ist ja das sind eigentlich so die 2 sachen also du machst aus mehreren platten eine
also du hast dann immer noch mehrere festplatten aber es sieht logisch nach einer aus
ok so genau war ich das gerne aus dem kopf na gut random retrites sagt weil du halt vor mehreren platten machen musst du musst ja quasi du musst ja random
du musst ja quasi auf 5 auf auf auf also also n-2 platten schreiben so first level eskaliert einfach alles
unser first level macht das wirklich ne also unser first level also ich muss sagen nicht also nicht der first level wo ich jetzt arbeite dort wo ich davor gearbeitet hab beim first level die konnten wirklich gar nix aber die wurden auch explizit dafür eingestellt dass sie gar nix konnten
die hatten da ich glaub 3 mädels waren es dann als ich da weg bin im first level die konnten 2 sachen die haben sich nett angehört am telefon und sie konnten ne standard antwort per mail schicken und haben es dann weitergeleitet
da gab es dann diese sagen umwobene mail was bei uns heute immer noch der running gag ist bei leuten die da auch gearbeitet haben so der techniker qualifiziert mit hochdruck ne wie haben sie geschrieben der techniker qualifiziert das problem und arbeitet mit hochdruck irgendwie sowas in der richtung so ne so ne schöne so schöne standard floskel die sie reingehauen haben immer egal ob da wirklich ein techniker dran gearbeitet hat oder nicht
das ist ja gut du hast immer leute die bisschen keine ahnung haben aber auf der anderen seite ich bin da mittlerweile ein bisschen wie soll ich sagen ein bisschen toleranter geworden gegenüber leuten die manche sachen nicht wissen weil es kann durchaus sein dass die leute eben einfach was anderes wissen als ich also ne ich mein klar du hast leute von denen merkst du quasi 2 mädels
20 km gegen wind dass sie absolut keinen plan haben vor nix aber es gibt durchaus leute die auch manchmal bei einfachen sachen fehlen aber trotzdem ahnung haben leider leider ist es oft mal so vorurteile kommen ja nicht so nicht so von ungefähr leider ist es halt wirklich oft mal so dass wenn du den eindruck hast der kerl hat keine ahnung dann stellt sich auch meistens raus ne da hat wirklich keine ahnung gerade bei den consultants die wir teilweise haben ich frag mich ja also ich weiß ich rantete öfters mal drüben aber consultants das wo
wort bedeutet ja eigentlich ich das ist jemand den ziehe ich hinzu den konsultiere ich bei was wo ich selbst keine ahnung von habe aber also ich will jetzt nicht sagen alle aber doch schon ein beachtlicher teil der consultants die wir hatten und auch jetzt immer noch teilweise haben ja ich weiß nicht so recht ja wozu man die eigentlich konsultieren sollte es ging eben um die
prüfung ja kannst du strukturam für nicht altile erklären ja kann ich machen pass mal auf strukturam das ist strukturam zu einem strukturam tust du so als würdest du programmieren aber du malst eigentlich was schwachsinnig ist was was schon was der erfinder sogar der erfinder dieses
dings gesagt hat dass es schwachsinnig ist das muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen sogar der erfinder hat gesagt es ist müll okay das hat er so nicht direkt gesagt das stimmt nicht aber sogar der erfinder hat schon gesagt das ist eigentlich nicht sinnvoll so und am besten das ist natürlich noch geiler das auch noch auf deutsch merke alle vorhanden für alle elemente von a merke dieses dieses nicht vorhanden element also das hier mal gucken
ob ich das noch mal gucken ob ich das noch auf außen aus dem kopf hinbekommen also das da ist eine schleife das da ist eine schleife das ist eine vorschleife also so quasi wie man das mal kopf gesteuerte schleife heißt es ja glaube ich so schön auf deutsch so das ist ein if
ein if ohne else das ist ein ganz normaler blog und das hier ist auch noch mal eine vorschleife und das hier ist auch ein ganz normaler blog was auch immer das sagen soll ja also mal ganz im ernst benutzen tut es eigentlich keiner auch wenn jemand geschrieben hat das kam letztens bei ihm in der bewerbung dran okay ja hätte ich nicht gedacht hätte ich nicht gedacht
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass so was noch in der bewerbung dran kommt
nein das machen wir übrigens heute gar nicht wie und jetzt und wie ging es dann weiter
ja gut sich einfach auf die prüfung vorbereiten also wenn du deine ab wenn du deine ausbildung bestehen willst da musst du dich halt auf die prüfung vorbereiten und die fragen ja mehr oder weniger im abstand von paar jahren alles das gleiche in der trailer ist leider noch nicht raus
aber ich warte also ich wollte eigentlich ein video heute oder morgen machen hat ein ganz anderes thema kein thema mit gaming und auch kein thema mit it und sonst was aber ich hebe mir das vielleicht auf falls morgen wirklich der battlefield 3
es ist so zu 90 prozent ist es bei uns leider so ich weiß nicht ob das ob das daran liegt dass ich mir einfach zu big brain vorkomme und es gar nicht so ist oder ob unsere consultants auch wirklich wenig ahnung haben wir haben auch leute die haben wirklich plan jetzt will ich gar nicht sagen aber gerade auch jetzt mal team übergreifen betrachtet was ich da schon für spezialisten teilweise hat es der wahnsinn das ist ich habe euch doch letztens erzählt
von dem entwickler der nicht wusste wie ein array in jason aussieht kann ich euch noch dran erinnern der immer gesagt hat ich will dass da aber zwei werte rauskommen wo ich ihm dann erklären musste das ist eine key value store da gibt es nur ein wert aber ich will dass da zwei werte rauskommen wo ich ihm dann gemeint habe ja dann hinterlegst als jason array dann sind es zwei werte ja aber ich will dass zwei werte rauskommen wenn das ausführen zweite zeile genau der typ das ist
ein consultant das ist ein fucking consultant das muss man sich mal vorstellen zu was will ich denn konsultieren wie man möglichst planlos den job bekommt wäre da guten consultant für was bedeutet merken soviel variable speichern würde ich sagen ja ist auch nicht schlimm brauche auch keiner für
wüsste ja hierzu wollte ich was sagen wisst ihr was meiner meinung noch besser ist besser ist als jedes struktur kramm oder oder irgendwelche komischen zeichnungen sonst was den kram einfach mal in der konsolenanwendung testweise programmieren also ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich kann irgendwie so so so 15 ko zeilen in der ordentlichen programmier sprache um welten besser lesen als irgendwelche struktur kramme als
irgendeine gute um als letztes mal vor als irgendwelche pups oder oder was ist da noch ichi cover diagramme oder was es da noch alles gibt einfach konsolenanwendung machen und mal ganz kurz zu grob das ausprobieren mit hardcoded werten meinetwegen konsolenanwendung machen ausprobieren und gut ist meiner meinung also meine persönliche meinung ist diesen diesen kram und und konsorten gibt ja noch mehr solche sachen braucht kein mensch
ich weiß es gibt genug leute sehen das anders aber ich finde es komplett sinnlos
kann ich einfach hoffen dass struktur kram nicht da kannst du hoffen die chance ist wahrscheinlich relativ gering aber du kannst ja ein handlungsstritt streichen auf der anderen seite das zeug ist nicht schwer also es ist nicht so als wäre das kompliziert es ist nur total unsinnig für für eigene
programme ist zu machen aber die hrk will das halt haben es gab heute ein paar gerüchte dass der trailer es gab heute ein paar gerüchte dass der dass der trailer droppt soll in kürze liegs am 6.
mai 6. mai ist doch morgen am 6. mai am 6. mai ist angeblich laut liegs der bell viel trailer warten wir es mal ab zumindest ist das eine gute gelegenheit dass ich mit dem lost mal wieder ein video machen kann ich habe
mich schon lange zeit mal überlegt im lost will ich gerne mal wieder was aufnehmen aber ja hat sich ja nicht so wirklich was ergeben also ich habe auf youtube kaum was gemacht auf twitch was komplett anderes mit battle royale was er sich hauptsächlich beschäftigt habe ich
nichts am hut gehabt jetzt biete sich das mal mit battlefield wieder ordentlich an so kurz weiter gucken wir in der prüfung der durchschnitt der zwischenprüfung lag bei 57 punkten von wie viel von 100
ohne mist mir hat schon eine pain zeichnung weitergeholfen manchmal bei ein paar programmierproblemen aber mit struktur kram noch nie jo wann liegst du dich bei einer million abos auf youtube ja wenn man viele verschiedene klassen und beziehungen und vielleicht auch noch vererbungsstelle hat lasse ich mir um l ja lasse ich mir um l ja gefallen übrigens zum thema auf papier programmieren ihr werdet ihr werdet was heißt ihr werdet mir nicht glauben doch ihr werdet mir glauben weil ihr das wahrscheinlich auch machen müsstet
wir haben in der berufsschule und wie gesagt 2007 das ist nicht dass es irgendwie steinzeit war oder so 2007 wir haben teilweise noch sachen auf papier programmiert es ist es ist halt absolut es ist absolut lächerlich letztendlich organikramme da haben sie bei uns jetzt etwas neues ausgedacht es passt mal auf also organikramme ist für uns zu einfach ich meine die firma wo ich arbeite aber das macht jede firma
feiert sich extrem darauf ab dass sie die geilsten der geilen sind aber das macht jede firma jetzt mal eine frage an euch macht es eure firma auch wahrscheinlich wenn es 90 prozent jetzt mit ja beantworten jede firma feiert sich übelst ab korrekt gesagt muss man eigentlich jedes unternehmen feiert sich übelst ab aber das haben alle gemacht wo ich bisher war aber die aktuelle auch und
und wir haben uns jetzt überlegt organikramme sind das ist einfach zu oldschool organikramme macht man macht man nicht mehr das ist das ist doof wir haben wir haben jetzt ein plugin was diese also was die und vielleicht ist es auch kein plugin vielleicht ist es auch out of the box ich weiß es nicht dass das jetzt im teams abbildet und wir haben das wir haben unser
organikramme und wir haben wir so hier archie haben wir jetzt auch in confluence im wiki als import leute das ist so fail das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht ich habe einen kollege bei mir im team der hat einen ganz anderen chef als ich fragt man sich ja wie das gehen soll das ist total kaputt und das beste ist die suche in dem teil funktioniert nicht richtig
ich wollte letztens wissen wer ist denn der ich will jetzt nicht den namen sagen ich umschreibe das mal wer ist denn der produkt manager für ein spezielles system also bin ich in diese in diese datenbank reingegangen da wo angeblich alle die produkte also die ganzen hier archien und und
verwaltungs sachen erfasst sind hab nach dem produkt gesucht hab das auch gefunden aber sekunde kein service manager drin kein produkt manager drin hat sie richtig gelohnt ja und und danach danach zwei tage später war dann derjenige der
dieses neue system eingeführt hat war bei uns in der team runde und hat das vorgestellt so und bei der gelegenheit habe ich mir gedacht ok den fragst du jetzt einfach mal wo das steht da habe ich ihn gefragt ja ok also ich
hatte letztens meine schwierigkeiten den service manager dafür den produkt manager dafür rauszukriegen ich habe da auch gesucht ich habe nichts gefunden und da macht er das auf screen sharing
screen sharing im teams auf geht in dieses geht in dieses portal rein und sagt ja wie hieß das jetzt was was haben sie gesucht und ja da und danach habe ich gesucht nach der ok ich zeige ihnen jetzt wieder
ok hat es eingegeben hat es gefunden hat es angeklickt und mein also da müssen jetzt und jetzt müsst ihr euch merken jetzt müsst ihr euch eine eine sache merken für für fail zu umschreiben nicht sagen das ist verkehrt oder sagen das haben wir vergessen
da hat gesagt da müssen wir noch einmal nachschärfen das ist auch eine gute umschreibe oder das ist so geile marketing management talk müssen wir noch einmal nachschärfen
ja so hat es dann ein paar chili flocken drauf gemacht ach keine blödsinn übrigens es ist bis heute nicht auffändbar ich habe es heute erst noch mal gesucht es ist nicht auffändbar ja vielleicht vielleicht ist er auch zu agil für mich das ist einfach das was ich suche ist so schnell und wechselt so schnell die plätze dass ich schon gar nicht sehe also wenn ich wenn ich es gefunden habe ist es schon wieder weg
wie da kann man nix streichen bei der abschlussprüfung
ja ja gut ich bin da mein übrigens leute da wollte ich auch mal wollte ich auch mal ein video zu machen ich bin der meinung man muss das alles mehr oder weniger pragmatisch sehen ich meine jetzt gar nicht so sehr rein in der it sondern bei fast allem es hat keinen
sinn zu diese üblichen diskussionen zu führen was ist besser ios oder android nvidia oder amd sony oder microsoft oder was auch immer sondern das beste ist man überlegt sich nicht was das beste ist irgendwie so so abstrakt das beste sondern man überlegt sich was muss man machen und was ist das einfachste und das einfachste ist in der regel das was man schon kennt also so blödsinn wenn man schon erfahrung hat in irgendwas und man kann das damit machen dann ist das in der regel das
einfachste und es hat keinen sinn sich irgendwie dann man gewinnt nix nur weil man der alpha fanboy von irgendwas ist das hat das hat überhaupt keinen sinn also man muss das nehmen was am besten für das geeignet also am besten oder am einfachsten für das geeignet ist was man
machen will und wenn es was ist was man schon kann umso besser und das heißt wenn es das einfachste für dich ist was hinzumalen nur weil ich das nicht sinnvoll finde heißt es ja lange nicht dass es für dich nicht sinnvoll ist deswegen einfach das machen womit man am besten klarkommt und sich ein bisschen weniger also das meine ich jetzt allgemein sich ein bisschen weniger von irgendwelchen anderen leuten erzählen lassen so nachdem auch so so ist das so ist das richtig ich habe euch doch mal erzählen
dass ich so einen webcast geguckt habe von so einem oba oba rubi guru der gemeint hat eine methode ist schon zu lang wenn sie mehr als eine zeile code enthält das war so das erste mal wo ich mir wo ich mir bewusst gedacht habe ok also in diesen konferenztalks wird auch richtig viel bullshit erzählt ich habe früher so diesen kram immer so blind irgendwie geglaubt und das gedacht oh das sind die richtig krassen oba rubi gurus pyson gurus
die schaap gurus die da auf konferenzen reden aber wenn du so ein stumpf sind hörst die methode über eine zeile ist code smell da denkst du dir auch ihr habt sie nimmer all nur one liner genau aber ich mein one liner da brauchst du dann einfach nen 100 100 zu 5 bildschirm
da fail ja ja ich werde mir das auf jeden fall kaufen wenn es was taugt ich werde es aber definitiv nicht vorbestellen ja natürlich das ist so sicher wie das arme in der kirche das ist ein battle royale
ja es ist so fehl dass man dass man 2021 auf papier programmieren muss hallo ja bei uns aber bei uns ändert sich das auch auf das bei uns ändert sich das ist eh witzig und das ist schon seit ich in der in der aktuellen firma bin bei uns ändert sich laufend irgendwas aber keiner schreibt das irgendwo hin
und alle tun dann immer so aber ich glaube das bin ich nicht die einzigen und alle tun dann immer so so nach dem motto ja wie das haben wir doch vor drei monaten schon gesagt das muss man doch jetzt langsam mal umsetzen das muss man doch jetzt langsam mal wissen
und dann fragst du mir okay gibt es das irgendwo zum nachlesen dass man weiß was man jetzt eigentlich machen soll nee das machen wir doch schon so lang das ist doch schon in fleisch und blut übergegangen das ist doch das leben wir doch jetzt schon das ist immer meine lieblingsantwort bei sowas wenn du ihn fragst ja wo ist das jetzt mal genau wo ist das denn beschrieben was ich machen soll und dann kommt dann einer von den stonksleuten um die ecke und sagt ja wie das leben wir doch schon seit jahren so nach dem motto wie das muss irgendwo stehen das musst du doch ganz automatisch wissen wie das richtig geht eine güte
also wir haben das ist bei uns schon der wahnsinn aber es hat sich die letzten jahre tatsächlich ein bisschen gebessert also ich glaube wir sind ja auf einem ganz guten weg
echt du warst bei wirecard naja da die feiern nicht mehr aber die haben sich bestimmt auch krass gefeiert
gut also man muss ja mal sagen das was die nasa gemacht hat 1970 hatte komplett andere anforderungen als 99,999 prozent aller business anwendungen heute und wir sind 40 jahre später 50 jahre später
was hältst du von confluence ich finde das ganz brauchbar
ja seh ich auch so leider sind die jetzt auf dem trip bei atlasien das gyra und eventuell confluence da bin ich mir nicht sicher nicht mehr selfhosted geht sondern man die cloud lösung verwenden soll
oh man musste was verschlüsseln das ist interessant so muss das sein und subscriben für mehr brain weil ihr wisst ja jeder sub ein iq punkt mehr für alle im chat
dementsprechend wenn ihr wenn ihr die prüfung bestehen wollt gibt es eigentlich also die einfachste war also die schwierige variante ist prüfungsvorbereitung machen fünf stunden am tag die einfache variante ist einfach prime sub und dann kommt das ganze von alleine
so siehts aus
vc dankeschön für den prime sub bf6 thema schon durch ich hab eigentlich noch gar nicht so viel dazu gesagt nee
ja das finde ich auch sinnvoll captain sammy danke für den sub da heider auch danke für den sub excellent subscriptions ja ja das finde ich auch sinnig ich gucke dass es dass die sachen die interagieren oft halt möglichst zusammenstehen dass man dann nicht
durch zig sachen durchspringen muss auch wenn es ein bisschen länger wird auferwatsch nee auferwatsch hab ich ganz lang nicht mehr angefasst und ich glaub auch nicht dass auferwatsch 2 was wird 1080p
ja also kommt drauf an ob du mehr wert auf auflösung oder auf fps legst also reichen reichen tut das bestimmt aber 27 zoll würde ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen höhere auflösung nehmen als 1080p
da würde ich aber auch gucken preisleistungsmäßig was da passt seh ich genauso ja seh seh seh ich genauso es wird es wird teilweise total übertrieben und das schlimmste was ich also meine persönliche meinung das schlimmste was gemacht wird ist man sagt an irgendwann so oh das ist so groß komplex und so und so träge geworden it mäßig bei uns und da kommt irgend so ein big brain
stonks mann auf die idee kein problem ab heute sind für agil ja und was heißt es jetzt yeah agil daily scrum stand up und dann war es das mehr passiert da nicht dann sind alle furchtbar agil und eigentlich ist es genau der gleiche kram wie vorher nur dass man im kreis steht also so ist das nicht so ist das nicht gedacht also gerade bei also ihr wisst ich bin in frankfurt so im finanz banken umfassen
fällt die sind halt nun mal sehr schwer ist schwerfällig ja und bei uns ist es auch bei uns ist es auch so dass man teilweise gesagt hat jetzt immer super agil hier in your face und was ist was ist was ist dann das was rausgekommen ist im prinzip ist alles beim alten und man steht einmal am tag 20 minuten im kreis auch nicht so sinnvoll dazu kommt dass wir und ich glaube das ist was was gerade in der finanz branche irgendwie
so ein problem ist das ist ein bisschen schizophren auf der einen seite versuchen sie super agil und modern zu sein IT technisch aber auf der anderen seite also das sind so zwei komplett entgegengesetzte versuche auf der einen seite versuchen super modern agil und und möglichst vielen leuten überlassen und sonst wie zu machen und auf der anderen seite soll jeder furz den du lässt lässt
prozess technisch abgestimmt dokumentiert koordiniert und bis aufs kleinste geplant sein das eine und das andere das kannst du einfach nicht zusammen machen alles im rahmen wunderbar aber dass das es kommt der punkt wo das eine das andere behindert irgendwann wisst ihr wie ich mein
ja das finde ich finde ich finde ich durfte das nicht also wir haben es noch sehr verhaustet aber kommt dann auch weg kannst du alternative zu kait empfehlen ich weiß gar nicht was kait ist weißt du wie man in schelle lgb w2 flasht wahrscheinlich so wie alle schelle dinger
du kannst du kannst du kannst schelle doch sogar direkt flaschen übers wappen dafür ist
musst du heute ein java backend das von studenten von mir oh pains jam pains jam ja da gestellt zwei für die subs kio kun 21 monate cute chat am start
me weep me spam modbucker if bän ich weiß nicht wie ich da grad drauf komm zock signal hatten wir schon mache ich nicht was hältst du davon dass alles in die cloud soll
kommen wir auf das umfeld an also ich finde das prinzipiell sinnvoll für viele unternehmen zu sagen hey wir betreiben kein wir betreiben eigentlich also kein eigenes rechenzentrum mehr beziehungsweise kein eigenen standort artista in der größe mehr
das kann schon seine vorteil haben es gibt nur eine sache die man sich halt abschminken muss und das ist dass das irgendwie großartig billiger ist also billiger ist das in der regel nicht man kann sich das sicherlich dann irgendwie schön rechnen wenn du noch ein paar leute kickst und sagst ja unser team vor ort musst du noch halb so groß sein dann vielleicht aber alles was ich bei uns bisher gesehen habe läuft daraus drauf dass das in der cloud eigentlich teurer ist als on-premise wie das so cool heißt man hat im
moment man hat ja kein eigenes rechenzentrum mehr was es läuft auch nicht offline oder sonst wie es läuft noch on-prem die richtig cool cloud natives die sagen on-prem so quasi alles außerhalb der cloud das ist schon nicht native cloud agil genug mehr ja ich finde das nicht schlecht also wir reden jetzt so im unternehmensumfeld ich kann das hat das hat seine daseinsberechtigung ja ansonsten im privaten umfeld finde ich das total hängen geblieben das
wäschetrockner in die cloud müssen dass sie funktionieren
guckt euch mal diesen guckt euch mal diesen reddit thread an die habe ich ja letztens gezeigt ist immer ein schönes beispiel dafür der typ der hat einen wäschetrockner von lg und hat jetzt festgestellt dieser wäschetrockner macht am tag ein gigabyte ein gigabyte
ich kann das nicht oft genug sagen leute wir reden ist ein gigabyte traffic daily up und down
ich weiß nicht ob der irgendwelche coins meint
aber selbst meinen meinen brauche ja keine bandbreite die chinesen sind schon in die china cloud so ein ding ist das hier zeigt mal her ultra large capacity
das ist ein wäschetrockner sag ich doch wäschetrockner mit mit sind q sink sink technology das ist auch so ein trend der eigentlich schon seit jahren vorbei ist dass man so eine coup davor macht twin wash
aber wahnsinn alter das zeug ist ganz schön teuer ich habe mir auch ein wäschetrockner gekauft vor ein paar jahren aber der hat glaube ich keine 1000
rund um auf 1200 euro gekostet du kannst dir die euro dollarpreise mehr oder weniger gleich nehmen
mein fack ja hier ein gigabyte weiß ich ob er weier schag ob er weier schag locks hat ich weiß übrigens auch nicht in welche richtung der der reddit thread
angegangen ist bei der gibt es noch jemand der reddit an sich mega pains champion findet mittlerweile auf dem smartphone du machst du machst eine google suche auf deinem smartphone es kommt reddit als antwort du klickst die google suche an und was kommt reddit sagt ihr install die app dass es angezeigt werden kann das geht mir extrem auf den sack also richtig auf den sack das ist richtig also wirklich hartkoer ätzend
so und man muss ja sagen das beste an reddit ist immer noch wenn man sich das im olddesign anguckt da kann man den kram wenigstens auch ordentlich lesen hier so guck dir mal wo wir letztens wieder das thema hatten endlos endlos scroll bei comments ich mein es ist warum werden bloß noch irgendwie bei vielen seiten 10 oder 20 kommentare geladen macht mein browser in irgendeiner art und weise einen
überforderten eindruck von 250 comments macht es irgendwie ein eindruck als könnte er nicht mehr anzeigen und vor allem wie lahm das auch ist mein reddit reddit lädt ja zum größten teil schon die ganzen comments aber youtube ist ganz schlimm hier mit mit endlos scroll
zumal der witz ist wenn du bei youtube runterscrollst was du machen musst wenn du beispielsweise ein paar seiten zurück misst ist trotzdem wieder alles geladen ich verstehe die logik nicht
ist das nicht auf java basis oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander unic dankeschön 5 monat subscriptions
ja ich denke auch also wenn ich bin 27 zoll kaufen würde habe ich ja nicht ich habe ja einen 24 zoll genau 24 zoll ich habe noch 1080p aber 240 herz 27 zoll würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch eine höhere auflösung kaufen aber ich muss sagen 240 herz fand finde ich schon gerade zum spielen nice
man braucht das nicht unbedingt also 60 herz sagt 144 herz ist vollkommen ok 240 herz ist nicer aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein riesen sprung von 60 auf 144
ja
ich kann dir einen guten ich kann dir einen guten it witz erzählen das ist mein absoluter lieblings it witz weiss nicht ob ich ihn nur erzählen soll oder
war wo ist das bild ja bester bester it witz aller zeiten das ist der beste
genau das ist ja nicht der puma chonk das ist der beste
das ist ja der witz in dem fall mit der schlange und dann aha programmiersprache
was meinst du was plein anderen
Komm mit dem Chat heute überhaupt nicht nachher. Was meinste, meinste auf dem Smartphone? Ich weiß nicht, worum was es da ging.
VBA? Das ist ja wirklich, äh...
Also, der Pains-Champ ist gar nicht mehr das richtige Wort für...
Press F-Champ, keine Ahnung.
Wann wechselst du deinem 360-Hertzmonitor? Gibt's das schon?
Oh, tatsächlich! Was kostet das?
Und ja...
Das kann man sich schon mal gönnen, oder?
696 Euro?
Äh, 90 Euro? Die Sache ist nur die, mir fällt kein Spiel ein, wo ich 360 FPS hinbekomme.
Selbst Battlefield 3 hängt irgendwie so bei 270 oder so.
Das ist der, der ist echt lustig, ne?
Echt doch, das ist mein Lieblingswitz. Also IT-Witz in der Richtung.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da eins mache, das kam ja nicht so gut an.
Oh, der ist wirklich schlecht.
Hast du eine Empfehlung für einen Raumlüfter, der die Luft säubert? Ne.
Könnte man eine Klimaanlage dafür nehmen, aber ne.
Ach so, der Witz, ja, das ist... Also, gut, man könnte jetzt sagen, Witze sind doof, wenn man sie erklären muss.
Ich hab ein Video darüber gemacht, wo ich das erkläre, aber das ist relativ einfach gesagt.
Python ist insofern eine High-Level-Programmiersprache und C ist eine Low-Level-Programmiersprache, was damit gemeint ist, dass du in C dich um viele Low-Level-Sachen selber kümmern musst.
Du musst dich in C beispielsweise um Management vom Arbeitsspeicher selbst kümmern.
Du musst dich darum kümmern, dass du Speicher belegst, dass du Speicher freigibst.
Du musst dich darum kümmern, um Speicheradressen, wo was steht.
Und Python macht das alles für dich.
Dementsprechend ist Python quasi High-Level, also höheres Abstraktionslevel als C.
So könnte man das glaube ich ganz gut umschreiben.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, das eine macht das andere nicht besser. Das sind einfach unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke.
Also wenn du, sag mal mal, irgendwelche Microcontroller-Sachen programmierst, dann wirst du das hauptsächlich damit machen.
Wohingegen, wenn ich mal schnell irgendwas skripten will, dann mach ich das vielleicht eher damit.
Das ist unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke.
Python ist aktuell die beliebteste, nee, bei JavaScript würde ich sagen, ist Python die beliebteste Programmiersprache, was Fans angeht.
Java ist sicherlich verbreitet da wahrscheinlich im Enterprise-Umfeld.
Aber wenn man sich mal die Sprachen anguckt, die Leute gerne verwenden und auch wieder verwenden würden, dann würde ich sagen, ist es zurzeit...
Die zwei beliebtesten Programmiersprachen sind eindeutig da aus meiner Sicht JavaScript und Python zurzeit.
Und auch gerade im Machine-Learning-Bereich ist das auch voll angesagt.
Also im wissenschaftlichen Bereich und im Machine-Learning-Bereich ist das auch voll angesagt.
Wohingegen, wenn du irgendwelche Betriebssystem-Sachen oder Microcontroller-Sachen machst, ist es C.
Und leider auch C++ bei C++ halt sackt und C ist ganz okay, aber C++ ist einfach Crap.
Was ist mit Micropython? Das kann man auch verwenden, aber ich bin da kein großartiger Fan von.
Mir ist das gerade auf dem ESP deutlich lieber mit C++ und das sagt schon alles.
Äh, ich muss übrigens mal mit dem Chat jetzt hinterherkommen.
Ah, ich hab's ja fast schon aufgeholt.
Äh, nein. Haha, nein, nein. Ich möchte jetzt davon nicht anfangen, weil ihr wisst, ich mag C++ nicht.
Ähm, also C++ tut so, als wäre es ein ähnliches Abstraktionslöffel wie Python.
Also sie versuchen da irgendwie mitzumischen, aber das Problem ist bei C++,
die implementieren viele, also sie versuchen viele sinnvolle Features zu implementieren, aber sie implementieren sie immer absolut unverständlich und menschenfeindlich.
Das ist das Problem an C++. Deswegen sackt C++ einfach nur.
Weißt du was? Ja, das ist die Standard-Python-Implementierung, die es in C programmiert, ja.
Oder? Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander? Ja, genau.
Nee, ist das was anderes?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist. Ich dachte immer, dass damit die Standard-Python-Implementierung gemeint ist, die in C programmiert ist.
Keine Ahnung, das ist doch was anderes. Ich hab keinen Schimmer.
So, richtig Monarch-S.
Hatte gestern einen Bewerbungsgepräch, der hat selbst mein Interviewpartner gesagt, dass Java Paynes-Champ ist. Hat er Recht? Hast du unterschrieben? Direkt?
Was ist das? Ein Reddit-Post, warum C++ sagt, oh, das ist genau das Richtige für mich jetzt.
Erstmal die ganzen Tracking-Links entfernen, wer weiß, wo man sonst rauskommt.
Also, of course, C++ is always different, ja. Ist leider so.
Console-Log, Print, System-Out, Printeln, FMT-Printeln, Konsolen-Pay, ja, genau das ist eines dieser Punkte, warum ich die C++-Logik nicht weiß.
Also, ich weiß, warum es so ist, ja. Und der olle Holländer, der das ursprünglich war, ich glaube, es war ein Holländer, der sich das ursprünglich ausgedacht hat, ne.
Der hat sich damals vielleicht auch was bei gedacht, aber es gibt so viele Programmiersprachen, die Konzepte gut implementiert haben, von denen könnte sich C++ einfach was abgucken.
Das ist schon, wenn ich diese komische Lambda-Sündach sehe in C++. Ich mein, wer hat sich gedacht, dass es eine gute Idee ist, einfach alle drei Klammern-Sorten, die es gibt, hintereinander zu verwenden dafür.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich bloß noch der da hinten dran oder so.
Ich mein, warum? Es gibt aber noch viel mehr Punkte, ich will da jetzt nicht anfangen. Ja, aber das ist typischer Fall von C++, wo die der Meinung sind, sie wissen es irgendwie besser.
Ja, man kratzt ja dann den Beruf schon nur an der Oberfläche. Ja, das wissen die beim C++-Cremium auch nicht, weil das würde nicht jeder was anderes machen.
Ja, C-Sharp ist eine schöne Programmiersprache. Ihr wisst ja, C-Sharp ist meine absolute Lieblingsprogrammiersprache. Ja, ganz viele hatten heute Abschlussprüfungen.
Ganz viele, und da haben auch schon viele was zu geschrieben, ja. Direkt gestylen, so ist gut.
Warum Java Pains-Champ? Nee, wenn man ehrlich ist, Java ist kein Pains-Champ. Java ist schon ganz okay. Ich hab leider auch kein Mittel gegen Java. Nee, aber ernsthaft, Java ist schon in Ordnung.
Ich flame Java nur immer ein bisschen. Weil, einfach weil es geht. Also bei C++ meine ich es ernst. Bei C++ bin ich wirklich davon überzeugt, dass es einfach eine absolut grottenschlecht designte Kack-Sprache ist.
Aber Java ist schon okay. Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Das finde ich, haben sie in C-Sharp jetzt ganz gut hingekriegt. Wusstet ihr, dass man in C-Sharp jetzt Programme schreiben kann, ohne dass man diese Standardgeschichte mit Namespace und Classes machen muss?
Das ist ein neues Feature in C-Sharp 8, glaube ich. Oder was? Nee, C-Sharp 9, C-Sharp 9.
Ja, hier. Das ist ein Hello World in C-Sharp jetzt. Früher sah das so aus, so wie in Java ein bisschen. Und jetzt, ab C-Sharp 9 kannst du es so schreiben.
Also sprich, wenn du kleine Sachen zum Ausprobieren machen willst, kannst du dir diesen ganzen Shit sparen und kannst einfach deinen Code hier direkt inline, also was, inline, direkt reinschreiben.
Finde ich eigentlich cool. Ich mein, unter der Haube macht er immer noch das da raus, aber was interessiert mich das?
Also da sieht man schon, Microsoft steckt da viel Gehirn rein, wie C-Sharp weiterentwickelt. Also ich muss sagen, ich hab ja angefangen C-Sharp zu lernen damals zu Dotnet 2, das ist schon ewig her.
Ich hab teilweise noch Eins-Einser-Zeiten mitgekriegt und es gibt eigentlich fast nichts, was sie eingeführt haben, wo ich sag, das ist total bescheuert.
Würde ich jetzt mal drüber nachdenken, es gibt bestimmt ein paar Sachen, das finde ich nicht so toll, aber es ist fast nichts dabei, alleine schon, dass mir jetzt so spontan nichts einfällt, nichts dabei, wo ich sagen würde, ultrakacke.
Und bei C++ kann ich euch von jedem Standard beim Durchgucken mindestens 10 Sachen sagen, die kacke sind.
Hat jemand einen Tipp, wie man C++ halbwegs schnell lernen kann, ohne schon Kenntnisse in C oder was? Es ist sogar gut, wenn du keine Kenntnisse in C hast, weil dann hast du die Erwartung, dass das irgendwie was Gescheites ist und das ist C++ halt nicht.
Das einfachste C++ zu lernen ist, du kaufst dir auf Amazon, wenn du ein bisschen Hang dazu hast, du kaufst dir hier so einen Controller, drei Stück für 18 Euro oder einen für 5 Euro und bastelst mal ein bisschen mit einem ESP32 rum.
Das ist in C++, dafür ist C++ auch echt ganz brauchbar und falls du ein bisschen Hang dazu hast und Spaß hast an so ein bisschen basteln mit Microcontroller oder irgendwie Elektronikkram, ist das eigentlich das Beste, was du machen kannst zum Lernen.
Da siehst du auch direkt was passiert und die Dinger haben WLAN, Bluetooth, USB direkt zum Flaschen, gibt ne super Visual Studio Code IDE dafür, die Zerstörung von C++.
Ich würde sowas auf YouTube ja tatsächlich machen, die Sache ist nur die, das ist eigentlich zu Nischenthema.
C Sharp besseres Java, wenn du mich fragst auf jeden Fall. Ich mein ein Vorteil hat C Sharp gegenüber Java, es hat nichts mit Oracle zu tun und ich glaube alles, wo man einen Bogen um Oracle machen kann ist gut.
Also das einzige, was ich bisher verwendet habe ist ganz ganz früher mal Eclipse, das war Hardcore Pains Champ und jetzt vor ein paar Monaten mal Dinge IntelliJ.
Verwendet eigentlich noch jemand NetBeans? Gibt es das noch? Gibt es noch, juckt aber kein mehr.
IntelliJ, genau das ist das. Die ganzen, ich verwende gerne die ganzen Jet-Prains Geschichten.
Ja wie gesagt, also ich hab ja selbst keine geschrieben, aber um jetzt mal den Chat zu zitieren, der eine sagt GR1 war gut, GR2 war kacke, der andere sagt GR2 war gut und GR1 war kacke.
Wieso sind sich alle eigentlich einig, das war Pains Champ aber okay. Was denkst du über GO oder Rust? GO ist cool, magisch, auch wenn ein paar Sachen unverständlich sind.
Das könnte aber daran liegen, dass ich zu Lowbrain dafür bin oder dass sie wirklich schlecht durchdacht sind.
Ich hoffe ja, dass GO mal mit Generics endlich um die Ecke kommt, die machen ja schon ewig rum und ergeblich kommt es jetzt auch demnächst.
Und dass man dann nicht mehr für jeden Scheiß Schleifenschachteln muss in GO, sondern auch immer eine ordentliche Filterfunktion für eine Liste bauen kann oder so, das geht ja aktuell nicht.
Was sind Generics? Generics ist, wenn du einen Typ für verschiedene, also mal angenommen, du hast eine Collection.
So und wenn du jetzt eine Collection hast, einen Array hast oder eine Liste, irgendeine Collection und du möchtest da unterschiedliche Datentypen drin speichern, die aber prinzipiell die gleichen Operationen unterstützen.
Also mal angenommen, du hast eine Klasse für eine Liste programmiert, die soll aber sowohl mit Ints funktionieren, die soll auch mit Strings funktionieren, die Liste soll auch mit Custom-Objekten oder sonst was funktionieren.
Dann machst du das mit Generics. Also im Prinzip sind Generics ein bisschen was wie Templates in C++, bloß nicht ganz so Paints-ChampiG.
Was ist mit Rust?
So Rust ist auch sehr nice, Rust ist aber only for high IQ Leute.
Was war denn noch schlimmer an Java-Generics? Das hatte irgendwie einen Haken, ich weiß gar nicht mehr was es war. Ich hab da irgendwann mal drüber was gelesen.
Was war nochmal? Irgendwas war richtig dumm. Irgendwas war richtig dumm an Generics in Java Skript.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr.
Was ist mit Python?
Im Enterprise Stonks Umfeld, wo ich auch arbeite, da ist das so.
Aber man muss sagen, Python ist ganz stark im Kommen. Und gerade bei modernen Sachen, es muss ja nicht gleich Sport-Rocker sein.
Es muss ja nicht gleich irgendwelche Startup-Geschichten sein. Aber gerade im Entwicklungsbereich, im Technologiebereich, im Science-Bereich, im Machine-Learning-Bereich, im Cloud-Bereich ist Python schon ziemlich angesagt und Richtung Cloud auch sehr viel in Go.
Braucht man das Using-System noch? Das Using-System brauchst du, damit du Console-Write-Line verwenden kannst.
Ansonsten du kannst es auch weglassen, dann müsstest du aber schreiben System.Console.Write-Line.
Wenn du Kinder bekommst, welche Programmiersprache würdest du ihnen beibringen?
Wisst ihr, was ich meine Kinder machen lassen würde zum Programmieren lernen, wenn sie denn wollen? Wie hieß dieser Typ? Nicht Karl? Carol? Nee.
Warte mal, wie hieß das nochmal? Dieses, äh, diese, ist das nicht Carol? Was? Kara? Was? Quatsch. Ist das nicht so?
Ja, aber das, das, das meine ich im Prinz-, ja das hier meine ich, genau das. Ah, Karin, so schau mal. Das meine ich, so war es hier in der Richtung. Das, das würde ich meinen Kindern zum Lernen geben.
Na, da kannst du, hast hier unten Aufgaben und die programmierst du, also du steuerst halt den Roboter. Du musst dann auch sowas wie schleifen machen und so. Das ist richtig cool.
Okay, das rechts mit irgendwelchen Samplerszeugen kann man mal außen vor, aber das ist eine richtig coole Idee. Also zum Lernen, das finde ich echt nice.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Das ist das im Endeffekt, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe. Man muss unter, also am einfachsten, man lebt am, also das Leben ist am angenehmsten, wenn man einfach das nimmt, was für die jeweilige, den jeweiligen Einsatzzweck am besten ist.
Das kann auch sein, dass es irgendwie eine Library gibt, nur für eine Programmiersprache, das aber halt mit Abstand die beste ist, dass man sagt, okay, den Teil zumindest mache ich halt dann darin.
Na, wie gesagt, bei meiner Webcam, also bei meiner Software für Webcam-Überwachung, der WebRTC-Teil, der ist auch in Go programmiert, weil Go, die mit Abstand beste WebRTC-Implementierung hat, die nicht C++ und Browsergeschiss ist.
Ja, genau, das kannst du machen. Das kannst du machen, ja.
Ja, Rosario, genau, das war ich meine.
Ja, das ist, ganz ehrlich, ich bin da auch kein Fan von. Also, ich bin nie warm, ich muss aber, also zu meiner Verteidigung sagen, ich hab auch nicht viel mitgemacht, aber es hat mich direkt angepainstchamped, dieses Xamarin, Xamarin Zeusch.
Ähm, und MVVM finde ich auch extrem boilerplate intensiv, vor allem wenn man kleine Sachen machen muss.
Wenn du mich fragst, für kleine Sachen, ja wir reden jetzt hier nicht von irgendwelchen Enterprise-Dingern, wo 20 plus Leute dran arbeiten und irgendwie sonst wie was unterstützt werden muss.
Es spricht nichts dagegen, seine Sachen ins Code-Behind-File zu schreiben. Auch wenn das bei ganz vielen total verpönt ist, aber für kleine Sachen, finde ich, muss man es nicht übertreiben.
Ja, wenn man 1, 2, 3 Fenster vielleicht hat und irgendwie ein paar Settings und so, warum soll ich es dann total übertreiben? Ja, das finde ich klappbar, C++ nicht so gut.
Klar, man, die prinzipielle Logik, kriegt man mit C++ hin, wenn man es mit anderen Programmiersprachen geschrieben hat. Das Problem ist, dass C++ an vielen Stellen nicht so funktioniert, wie man sich vorstellt.
Es ist einfach, ah, C++ tut weh an so vielen Stellen.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Tribolon, danke schön, du hast 18 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier. Ich glaube, du gehst mit dem Chat absolut nicht hinterher, ich bin glaube ich eine Stunde nur am Chat lesen.
Notepad++, ja meinetwegen, also ich finde Notepad++ jetzt in der heutigen Zeit ehrlich gesagt ziemlich überflüssig, wenn man Visual Studio Code verwenden kann.
Ich glaube, der einzige Vorteil von Notepad++ gegenüber Visual Studio Code ist tatsächlich die Startzeit, das war es dann aber auch.
Zum Glück geht das immer weiter von Oracle weg, weil alles, was mit Oracle zu tun hat, ist ja schon Payne's Champ extrem.
Genau, genau, wenn man schon die Idee hat, was man machen will, ist schon mal die halbe Miete.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist schon die halbe Miete.
Genau, genau, wenn man schon die Idee hat, was man machen will, ist schon mal die halbe Miete. Nee, genau das da meine ich.
Ja, C++ Templates auch. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das für die Sprache spricht.
Ja, Groovy ist die einzige Sprache, mit der ich jemals was bisschen Umfangreicheres gemacht habe, die auf der Java Virtual Machine läuft.
Ja gut, das Cobol Master Race sind wir uns hier glaube ich einig. Dicht gefolgt von ABAP und Fortran.
Das ist sicherlich auch cool, das habe ich nie verwendet.
Weiß jemand, wie es ist, Solution Architekt zu sein? Klingt nach einer Stonks Position, wo du dich gut verkaufen können musst. Keine Ahnung.
Ich mache hier keine Bilder auf. Ja, so sieht es aus.
Kann man mit C-Sharp mittlerweile eine Plattform über Grafit Guis entwickeln? Theoretisch schon. Praktisch gibt es ein paar Hindernisse.
Also es gibt, von Microsoft gibt es ja dieses ganze Samorin-Gezeug, das ist aber meiner Ansicht nach hauptsächlich auf Mobilsachen zugeschnitten.
Ja, man kann da theoretisch Linux, Mac und Windows mitmachen. Ob man das machen will ist wieder was anderes.
Dann gibt es jetzt im nächsten Maui, das ist quasi Samorin 2.0 mit den gleichen Problemen. Höchstwahrscheinlich.
Zum Beispiel, dass sie keine Steuerelemente selbst malen, sondern immer das nehmen, was auf der jeweiligen Plattform verfügbar ist.
Habe ich ja schon öfter gesagt, bin ich kein großer Fan von. Ich finde, da macht es flatter besser.
Dann gibt es so Sachen wie Avalonia UI noch, habe ich aber noch nie verwendet, kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Also prinzipiell geht das, aber ich glaube, es gibt immer noch ein paar Hürden.
Erwing. Ich habe früher auch öfters mal Emacs verwendet, aber schon seit Jahren nicht mehr.
Dankeschön für 10.000 Euro.
Alles, was kein Elektron ist, ist ja prinzipiell schon mal gut. Wobei man sagen muss, ich glaube,
Visual Studio ist die einzige Elektron-Anwendung, die ich täglich dauerhaft offen habe.
Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Das Problem an Qt ist,
es ist C++. Oder man nimmt eine andere Sprache, aber spätestens, wenn man irgendwelche Erweiterungen machen muss, dann bleibt man bei C++ hängen.
Ey, jetzt bin ich zu brain dead für die Uhrzeit.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich, wird aber wahrscheinlich ziemlich groß. Also man könnte theoretisch Cross-Platform GUIs mit Unity machen.
Den gehe ich mal von aus, das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren, ja.
Discord ist doch auch Elektron.
Ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee.
Discord ist doch auch Elektron, ja.
Discord ist Elektron, die haben allerdings paar C-Extensions noch dabei. Die wollen es richtig krass wissen bei Discord.
Übrigens habe ich euch schon erzählt, dass ich jetzt Prioritätsgruppe 3 bin, weil ich in kritischer IT-Infrastruktur arbeite.
Also, merke, da geht es um Leben und Tod bei mir, ja.
Wenn die Stonks nicht mehr laufen, dann ist die Kacke am dampfen.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht so genau. Ehrlich gesagt bin ich der Meinung, die sollten lieber die Leute impfen, die es wirklich nötig haben.
Zumindest die, die neu geimpft sind, weil ich kann ohne Probleme von daheim ausarbeiten und bei mir geht es halt nur ums Geld, nicht wirklich um Menschenleben.
Aber, wie wir ja alle wissen, wenn man die Auswahl hat, eine richtige Position zwischen Geld und Menschenleben, dann ist klar, dass sich da viele für Geld entscheiden.
Dementsprechend bin ich halt auch in kritischer Infrastruktur tätig, ja.
Freust du dich schon wieder aufs Büro?
Nee.
Gar nicht.
Aber das Schöne bei uns ist, es gibt jetzt eine vom Betriebsrat abgesegnete Homeoffice-Regel.
Das ist das erste, was ich machen werde, wenn Dauer-Homeoffice vorbei ist.
Pock.
Pock. Schaffe ich es heute noch mal im Chat unten anzukommen?
Ja, okay, mit 36 ist man ja, ich weiß, da ist man schon fast im Altersheim.
Oh, ich habe es geschafft, ich bin im Chat unten.
Mit 3F, Dankeschön, 8 Monate, Hypersubscription, Pockers.
Übrigens, habt ihr schon die News des Tages gesehen?
Wisst ihr, dass Bill Gates lässt sich scheiden?
Ups.
Bill Gates lässt sich scheiden.
Bill Gates kommt jetzt, genau.
Ist das schon von gestern?
Na ja, komm, vor einer Stunde, vor 11 Stunden.
Ey, komm mal, sogar Promi-Flash war erst vor einer Stunde dran, ja.
Ja, ja, okay, ich, ja, ich, ich, okay, ich bin, ich bin outdated, ja, okay, alles klar, ist, ist gut.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch aber noch mal was ganz Neues für die Leute in Frankfurt, Hanau und Umgebung.
Ähm, Hanau.
Hier, guck mal, das ist, das ist, keine Ahnung, ein paar hundert Meter von mir weg.
Hanau plant gigantisches Rechenzentrum, und zwar private Investor möchte auf dem Gelände ehemalige Großauheim-Kaserne...
Ich weiß, wo das ist.
Na, okay, ein paar hundert Meter ist übertrieben.
Äh, ist untertrieben.
Es ist doch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Das ist Maps Hanau.
Das, das dürfte schon eher so...
Zwei Kilometer oder so weg sein. So, und, ups, das ist hier unten irgendwo, äh...
Hier ist das, glaube ich.
Irgendwo hier, glaube ich, war die, hier war die Kaserne irgendwo früher.
Moment, warte mal.
So, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich.
Warte mal.
So, und da wollen die jetzt was hinbauen.
Nee, Moment, ich bin, ich bin falsch.
Nee, das kotz.
Nee, doch, ich bin richtig. Die Kaserne war hier irgendwo.
Na, also, ihr seht, hier ist viel Platz.
So, und hier wollen sie ein fettes Rechenzentrum draufbauen.
Und ich predikte jetzt schon mal was.
Ich hab das ja grad, ich hab's ja grad auf Twitter geschrieben.
Ähm, ich, ich, ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Hier ist sehr viel Wald.
Wo die das hinbauen wollen.
Hier, hier war die ehemalige Kaserne.
Hier.
Hier ist sehr viel Wald und sonst was.
Die finden garantiert
irgendwelche seltenen Frösche,
die gerade dort
leichen oder die
seltene Vögel, die
brüten oder irgendwas.
Also,
ich wäre sehr
überrascht, wenn die das da wirklich bauen würden.
Zumal das Gerücht schon vor drei,
vier Jahren mal rumging,
dass das gebaut wird.
Da hat man nie wieder was gehört und jetzt sind's
jetzt, also es ging vor drei bis vier
Jahren mal das Gerücht
rum, Amazon möchte hier
ein Rechenzentrum bauen. Und ich gehe auch mal
von aus, sie wollten und es hat nicht
geklappt wegen irgendwelchen
Fröschen oder, oder weil sie mit
der Stadt nicht klar gekommen sind.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Zumindest ist das für mich
Arbeitgeber-technisch
keine Alternative, weil
vor Ort in
diesem Rechenzentrum ist ja nichts.
Da braucht's
so ein paar Tech, da braucht's so ein paar Turnschuh-Admins,
die rumlaufen, Rechner einbauen
und sonst was.
Da habe ich keinen Bock
mehr drauf. Das habe ich früher gerne gemacht.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
würde ich es heute immer noch gerne machen, weil mit Hardware
auszumachen ist immer noch cool.
Aber bezahlungstechnisch
ist das, glaube ich, deutlich
unter dem, was ich da jetzt kriege und was ich jetzt
mache. Ich meine, das wäre cool, ich
müsste nicht weit fahren, ja.
Ich meine,
Hetzner könnte da einen Standort hinbauen, dann.
Tja.
Aber ich wollte gelesen,
jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt, ob das klappt.
Wenn man sich entschieden hat, so was zu bauen, geht das ja relativ
schnell.
Ich meine, für so ein Rechenzentrum brauchst du nichts.
Das wichtigste für ein Rechenzentrum sind
eigentlich Gegebenheiten drum herum,
ja. Also Kühlung,
Kühlungsstells, wie auch immer, die das da
machen wollen, Strom, also Strom,
Kühlung und
in irgendeine Art und Weise Anbindung
an irgendwelche Backbones.
Also das eigentliche
Rechenzentrum da hinzustellen, das
geht relativ schnell.
Ja,
ich bin mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
Was ist denn sonst? Ist sonst noch
irgendwas Wichtiges passiert?
Wie gesagt, ich habe nichts Großartiges
geplant für den Stream heute. Ach ja,
stimmt, heute Morgen gab es,
weiß jemand, was für Neuerungen mit
iOS, mit iOS 14.5
gibt?
Heute Morgen haben meine iPhone gesagt, ich soll
upgraden.
Ah ne,
es gibt eine Sicherheitslücke.
Super.
Alle Neuerungen, okay.
Was gibt's, was gibt's Neues in
iOS 14.5?
Vielleicht funktioniert ja Safari endlich mal
wieder gescheit, aber da habe ich keine Hoffnung
für. Oder sag mal, Safari
funktioniert ja prinzipiell
schon ganz gut,
aber mit der Unterstützung
moderner Web-Technologie tut
sich Apple schwer.
In Safari. Und nachdem es
unter iOS keine anderen Browser gibt
als Safari,
hast du ja gelitten.
Also du bist ja auf Gedi und Verderben
Google aus, nicht Google,
Apple ausgeliefert.
Es gibt keinen anderen Browser unter
iOS als Safari.
Das ist alles nur Placebo.
Nein, es gibt
auch keinen Firefox für iOS.
Du kannst zwar aus dem
App Store.
Nein, gibt es
nicht. Gibt es nicht.
Ich weiß, das irritiert immer
alle, wenn ich das sage, aber gibt es nicht.
Das ist Placebo.
Du hast zwar im App Store
einen Chrome, einen Firefox
und einen Edge, die sind unter
der Haube aber alles Safari.
Das einzige, was die Browser
unter iOS machen, ist ein eigenes Fenster
um Safari zu malen.
Apple erlaubt
keinen anderen Browser
außer Safari auf der Plattform.
Das ist
Policy bei Apple. Also wenn ihr denkt,
ihr verwendet Chrome unter iOS,
ihr verwendet nicht Chrome.
Ja, das ist so.
Ihr verwendet
einen Safari, der ein bisschen
aussieht wie ein Chrome.
Hahaha, cake weight.
Da hatten wir es doch heute schon von.
Öfters schon davon.
Noch ein Grund weniger für Apple. Ich finde, es gibt
relativ viele gute Gründe für Apple.
Es ist halt die Frage, was man machen will.
Ja, also nein, es gibt
wirklich keinen anderen Browser
unter iOS als Safari.
Dementsprechend ist ja auch das Problem,
wenn in Safari was nicht funktioniert,
kannst du es nicht verwenden
unter iOS.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel gescheite PWAs
haben willst, mit Notification
oder sowas, kannst du nicht machen
unter iOS, weil
Safari unter Android
kein Problem, sowohl mit Firefox als
auch mit Chrome, da können die das. Was meint ihr denn,
warum ein Chrome unter iOS keine Notifications
kann? Keine PWA
Notifications, aber
unter Android das funktioniert.
Das liegt schlicht und ergreifend daran,
weil Chrome und Firefox unter
Android eben ein Chrome und ein Firefox ist
und unter iOS, ein Chrome und ein Firefox,
eben ein Safari ist mit einem anderen
Fenster.
Ich habe
absolut keine Ahnung.
Alle, alle
Browser, alle Browser
unter iOS sind Safari.
Die sind einfach nur
ein bisschen anders von der Bedienung
her, die haben ein anderes Fenster,
haben vielleicht auch ein paar zusätzliche Features,
aber die Render-Engine,
beziehungsweise die Browser-Engine, das ist bei
allem Safari.
So, also zeig mal, was gibt's denn bei 14.5
neues? Also gescheiten Browser
wahrscheinlich schon mal nicht. Mehr Sicherheit
für neue Emojis,
das müssen wir haben.
Ein Emoji für eine
bärtige Frau ist komplett neu.
Da wäre ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder gesteinigt, wenn ich das sage,
aber darauf hat sicherlich die Welt gewartet.
Aber warum nicht?
Ich hab ja da auch nichts gegen.
Es gäbe aber
durchaus sinnvolle Emojis, die man einbauen
könnte. Zum Beispiel
Get Emoji,
zum Beispiel in Windows,
in Windows,
ich hab's euch ja gestern schon gezeigt,
in, in
alle
haben ein Window Emoji,
alle, außer
Leute, wer fehlt hier?
Window Emoji,
wer fehlt hier?
Apple hat's, Google hat's,
Samsung hat's, Whatsapp, Twitter
hat's, alle haben sie's.
Nur Microsoft fehlt.
Warum Windows bis heute
keinen Window Emoji hat, verstehe ich nicht.
Gut, aber ich geb zu, das hat mit
mit IOS ja nichts zu tun.
Ja, aber
ja, aber
meinetwegen, dann haben wir jetzt halt auch
eine bärtige Frau als Emoji.
Wie sieht denn das aus?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Es gäbe aber auch tatsächlich noch
jede Menge andere sinnvolle Emojis,
die man einbauen könnte, ne?
Gerade, gerade so Dinge,
Dinge des täglichen Lebens,
da geht's mir öfters mal so. Mein Essen
gibt's ja in allen möglichen Varianten,
aber, aber Gegenstände
fehlen mir öfters mal, ja.
So, wie sieht denn das aus?
Neue Emojis,
4.5 IOS.
Ok, also gucken wir mal.
Ok, es gibt jetzt
Love, es gibt jetzt
Girl Girl Love,
Man Man Love, in unterschiedlichen Hautfarben
mit Herzchen und allem.
Ok, es gibt
MonkaS, Smoke,
Leute, die haben uns das Emote geklaut
bei Apple.
Die haben
eindeutig, oder?
Anzeige
ist raus, die haben eindeutig das Emote
geklaut.
Hier
Emojipedia,
ja, gucken wir gleich mal.
So, äh, hier.
Couple Emojis,
Smileys,
ja,
MonkaS, Smoke.
Hearts gibt's neu auf
verbunden.
Hearts on fire,
Hearts on fire.
So, äh, äh,
Gender Consistency.
Ach, jetzt gibt es tatsächlich, hier,
guck mal das.
Man with a beard
haben wir jetzt.
Und auch in allen,
ey, der Typ hier, der da,
der da,
wisst ihr, wie der aussieht?
Wie dieser Meme
Kopf. Ich weiß nicht, wie dieses
Meme heißt, so dieses
Man don't cry Meme. Wisst ihr, was
ich mein? Der Blonde, der
immer von der Seite so guckt auf dem
Bild. Nein, ich halte
Pain, nein, nein, nein, nein, Quatsch.
Den kenne ich doch.
Chat Meme,
okay, das ist teuer. Das könnte da
sein. Den da meine ich, genau.
Fühlt ihr dich auch, dass das schon
durchaus gewisse Ähnlichkeiten hat, so dem Tut?
Sagt aber, hat schon gewisse
Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Nordic Gamer.
Nordic Gamer, genau.
Das wird es sein.
Genau das meine ich.
Felix, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Okay, also.
Frau mit Bart gibt es jetzt nicht. Moment.
Wait a minute.
Das ist doch nicht.
Das ist Mann mit langen Haaren
auf dem Emoji.
Das ist doch, das ist doch eindeutig
das gleiche Gesicht, oder?
Oder nicht?
Sind das unterschiedliche Gesichter?
Stimmt, die Augenbrauen sind anders.
Weil ansonsten hätte ich gesagt,
Mann mit langen Haaren.
Okay, okay.
Dann ist es tatsächlich Frau mit Bart.
Okay.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Geh mal fort.
Ah, die haben es zensiert.
Die haben das Blut weggemacht.
Ach ne, sie haben das Blut weggemacht,
sie haben das Blut weggemacht, dass es besser für Corona passt.
Okay.
Sagte mal.
Jetzt wo ich hier gerade war
von Airpods. Was ist denn eigentlich
aus Beats
bei Dr. Dre geworden?
Wurden die nicht auch gekauft
von Apple?
Was, was ist denn, gibt es das?
Oder Beats?
Ich kann mich auch dran erinnern,
wo sogar Christiano Ronaldo
damit rumgelaufen ist
und gemeint hat, ich mag den Bass
davon. Das war ja auch das einzige,
was zumindest die erste Generation konnte.
Die erste Generation konnte Bass.
Die zweite Generation habe
ich nie persönlich gehört.
Sollen wohl deutlich besser gewesen sein.
Gibt es das noch?
Okay, gibt es anscheinend immer noch.
What the fuck? Was ist denn das?
Sieht aus wie so ein komisches
wichtig to business enterprise
Headset.
Örgerät. Das sieht aus wie ein Örgerät, ja.
Okay, Moment. Ich muss mal gucken, was die
jetzt kosten.
Alter, was ist aus den normalen Kockereien?
350 Euro!
Haben die, wie gesagt,
ein ordentliches Noise-Cancelling?
Haben die ordentliches Noise-Cancelling?
Ich meine, für den Preis kann ich mir
schon die Sony Noise-Cancelling
Kopfhörer kaufen, die richtig guten.
Und ihr wisst, ich bin kein großartiger
Bose-Fan, aber ich habe selbst das
einzige, was ich von Bose habe, sind die
Noise-Cancelling-Kopfhörer, weil das
Noise-Cancelling damals mit Abstand das
Beste war, aber mittlerweile sind die
Sony-Dinger wohl auch ziemlich gut
und ja, wahrscheinlich hat Zenhizer
mittlerweile auch irgendwas.
Na gut, egal, das kaufe ich eh nicht.
Würde ich nie kaufen.
Immer noch günstiger als AirPods. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was bei
Apple los ist.
Okay, desktop-Computer, Laptop,
Mobile und so, das ist jetzt Apple-branded,
alles klar. Also sprich, der
Desktop-Computer bei Apple ist jetzt eine
Mac.
War das nicht vorher auch schon?
Okay, kommen wir.
Ja gut, langweilig, okay.
Gibt es sonst, also ich meine, wenn
Emojis schon die größte Neuerung an
iOS 14.5 sind, dann gibt es ja
wohl nichts, oder nicht?
So oder nicht viel, ne?
Entsperren trotz Maske.
Aha.
Hä?
Warum muss ich das? Warum kann mich die
Kamera, das müsst ihr mir jetzt mal erklären,
Chat. Warum kann mich die Kamera
von meinem iPhone mit
Maske besser erkennen, wenn ich eine Apple-Watch
an hab?
Oder tracken die noch mal in Herzschlag
und gucken, ob ich's bin?
Zusätzlich.
Aber ich kann mit der Uhr
entsperren. Hä?
Ah, du entsperrst die Apple-Watch
und entsperrst dann das Handy mit, wenn's gekoppelt
ist, oder wie? Aha.
Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, okay.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab die Maske
wenn ich draußen bin an der Luft,
hab ich nie ne Maske, ich hab immer ne Maske
dabei, in der
in der Hose, aber wenn ich an der
frischen Luft bin, hab ich keine Maske auf.
Wozu?
Oder erkennt mich auch mal ein iPhone, wenn ich
irgendwo reingehe, ja dann, dann schon.
Praxis Corona,
hä? Hä? Wenn du bei frischer Luft und Wind
und Sonnenschein keine Maske aufhast,
fehlt nicht mal viel zum Corona-Leugner,
ja.
Farbstichfehler behoben.
Weißabgleich ein.
Siri-Kurzbefehle.
Tja, ich glaub wir werden das nie erleben,
dass die
also Siri-Shortcuts, das hieß ja
früher Workflow, Workflowy,
Workflow oder so, dass das mal an
Tasker oder sowas von Android rankommt.
Leider. Ich glaube,
das liegt aber nicht
an Tasker oder es liegt nicht
an Siri-Shortcuts,
das liegt an der, also es liegt
an den Beschränkungen der jeweiligen
Plattform, dass Apple das halt nicht will.
Hä, also es ist zum Beispiel
undenkbar, dass du
äh, beispielsweise eine Automation
machst auf dem iOS-Gerät,
was automatisch
den Browser öffnet, oder
deine Kamerasoft eröffnet, wenn
deine, also wir reden hier von automatisch,
wir reden hier von automatisch, wir reden nicht
hier von, äh, Message schicken,
anklicken, öffnen, Finger
drauf halten, Face-ID machen, dann geht's
auf, sondern automatisch öffnen,
wenn beispielsweise eine
an der Tür klingelt, klingt. Kannste vergessen.
Ähm,
das geht nicht, weil Apple, weil die Apple
Restriktionen lassen
das nicht zu. Das ist ja auch sinnvoll,
wenn man das einfach
nur verwendet und wenn man
damit normalen Betrieb
macht, auch unterwegs, unterwegs
ist und das sicher haben will,
dann soll sich das nicht einfach
entsperren, aber wenn man sowas zum Beispiel
als, äh, Dashboard verwenden will
für Heimautomatisierung und hängt
sich so ein iPad an die Wand, ich hab mir das ernsthaft
überlegt, ihr wisst ja, ich hab zwei
Amazon Fire HD 10s an der Wand
hängen als Heimautomatisierung Dashboard
und da hab ich mit Tasker so eingerichtet,
die Dinger entsperren sich automatisch,
es geht automatisch die Kamera
auf, wenn eine an der Tür klingelt.
Und das ist halt nicht möglich mit
iPad, das geht halt nicht. Wo wir wieder beim
Thema sind, man muss sich einfach das
kaufen und das nehmen für den jeweiligen
Anwendungszweck, was
passt. Hast du dir jetzt eigentlich einen
E-Scooter gekauft? Nein, hab ich nicht.
Und den LED-Rucksack
hab ich mir auch nicht gekauft, ne, ne.
So, Fehlerbehebung haben wir.
Datenschutz für iPads.
Was?
Moment mal, was?
Apeis werden die Tablets mit Hilfe einer Smartphone
hier die Verbindung zum eingebauten
Mikrofon kapern, sobald die...
Kapern?
Kappen! Kappen!
Will der schreiben, nicht kapern, oder?
Kapern heißt ja übernehmen.
Da wird ja nichts übernommen, sondern es wird
gekappt, sobald die Hülle geschlossen wird, oder?
Moment, was ist denn ein Smart Folio?
Das ist die Hülle.
Ne, das meiner ist kappengemeint.
Startbildschirm im Querformat.
Ja, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Safari, oh, mal gucken, die huge Neuerung
für Safari.
Okay, geil, beste.
Also moderne Web-Technologien in Safari
immer noch nicht, alles klar.
Software-Updates.
Ah ja, Apple-Musik juckt mich null.
Siri juckt mich auch null.
iPhone-Suchen juckt mich auch null.
Ich muss es ja nicht bezahlen, wenn es weg ist.
Was ist denn mit Weird-Champ los?
Wie gibt es nicht?
Ist das entfernt?
Haben wir keinen?
Weird-Champ, ist der weg?
Ich habe mal wieder neu zum Channel geadded, FFZ.
Sie nehmen uns unsere Emojis, ja, wo soll das auch hinführen?
Was, Trainingsmöglichkeiten und Controller?
Ja, es juckt mich auch nicht.
Batteriegesundheit juckt mich auch nicht.
Okay, also ich sehe, es ist nichts dabei,
was mich großartig interessiert bei iOS 14.05.
Alles klar, top.
Exzellent.
Ich frage mich echt, ob morgen der Battlefield 6-Trailer droppt.
Mal gucken, ob es Neuigkeiten gibt.
Reddit-Battlefield.
Was hältst du von Lofi-Musik?
Ja, als Musik für Hintergrund,
und dass irgendwie was dudelt, ist schon okay.
Es ist nicht, dass ich sage, oh, ist das so nice.
Für den Hintergrund, dafür ist es ja auch gemacht,
ist das schon ganz okay.
Ihr wisst ja, wenn es mir geht, Heavy-Metal beste.
In Wirklichkeit Gachibuster nicht, sondern Headbanged.
Levelcap energy baitet uns wieder.
Leak, wie, hier gibt es nichts zu Leaks, was soll das?
Den habe ich live gesehen, vor Ort,
bei einem Battlefield-Event, diesen Trailer.
Und das war, ich habe es Dobi schon mal erzählen,
das war einfach Fail, wie das gelaufen ist.
Wir sollten eigentlich einen USB-Stick bekommen,
wo Trailer und Material drauf ist.
Und wir haben uns schon verabredet,
war unter anderem damals noch der Lost mit dabei,
dass wir nachher im Hotel direkt nach dem Event was aufnehmen.
Und was war, es gab keine USB-Sticks und nichts.
Und wir waren langsamer, obwohl wir vor Ort bei dem Event waren,
wir waren langsamer mit unseren Videos damals zu Battlefield 1,
als Leute, die einfach online den Reveal-Stream geguckt haben.
Das war richtig Fail.
Auf so Events gehe ich auch nicht mehr,
das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt.
Also rein aus Stonks Sicht hat sich das nicht gelohnt.
Die Leute Real-Life zu sehen war nice,
aber ansonsten gibt es hier nichts zu Battlefield Leaks.
Warum, was ist hier los?
Ich will Results gucken.
Keine Leaks und nichts?
Ich bin schwer enttäuscht.
Schwer enttäuscht, Suchfilter, letzte Stunde.
Die haben es auch mitgekriegt, dass neues Battlefield kommt.
Wobei das ist glaube ich nicht Russisch,
das ist eher Polnisch oder sowas.
Polnisch, Tschechisch oder irgendwie so.
Also es ist ja PL, sieht man ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die ernsthaft was über das Spiel Battlefield schreiben.
UAV Gets Enhanced Capabilities.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es dort um das Spiel Battlefield geht,
sondern eher um Real-Life Battlefield Geschichten.
Sackt.
Ich hoffe der Trailer kommt morgens, wäre echt cool.
Aber wahrscheinlich wird es so sein, wie ich letztens gesagt habe,
die bringen morgen so einen 2, 3, 4, 5 Sekunden Teaser
und der Trailer kommt dann irgendwann nächste Woche.
So was immer, ja da hast du recht, die sind nicht schlecht.
Aber ich dachte mir halt, wenn es schon ein Subreddit gibt,
für das jeweilige Spiel, die sind da auch immer scharf drauf, aber nope.
Yet Another League, vor 6 Stunden.
Ok, was hat er dann geleakt schon wieder?
Hold Back Boom.
Aha, das ist jetzt schon ein League?
Moment, das geht jetzt schon als League durch?
Krasses League.
Hold Back Boom.
Fuck, Alter.
Massive League.
Ach so, da, da hat er.
Die haben es einfach nur.
Ist das denn hier ernst?
Huge League.
Massive, Alter.
Das ist so was.
Solche Szene hätte ich mir in Battlefield ja im Traum nicht ausmalen können.
Das ist ein Offspray.
Ja, das ist das einzige, was ich erkannt habe.
Aber was für ein Spaß in das League, Alter.
Was für ein Spaß in das League, Alter.
Was für ein Spaß in das League.
Was für ein Scheiß League.
Ich gebe da überhaupt nichts drauf.
Ich gehe übrigens davon aus,
dass zumindest der eine Screenshot
legit war.
Wenn ich beide
und mal schauen, was da
kommt.
160 Upvotes.
Wer gibt's nicht?
Geiler Scheiß.
Da gibt's viele.
Da gibt's vieles und nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da so, was ich zeigen muss.
Ich benutze ganz vieles Zeug.
Screenshot, ja.
Es gab doch vor ein paar Tagen, gab's doch diese komischen.
Hab da doch wahrscheinlich schon zum größten Teil gesehen.
Hier.
Vor ein paar Tagen gab's doch diese komischen
Screenshots hier. Das da.
Und das andere haben sie gar nicht mehr drin.
Also das hier.
Das ist Quelle EA?
Wie jetzt?
PC Games Hardware League
Confirmed?
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht Quelle EA.
Das sind die Bilder,
die sie auf Twitter gepostet haben.
Die kommen angeblich aus dem
geleakten Reveal
Trailer.
Also bei dem Ding, keine Ahnung.
Aber das hier sieht schon sehr legit
aus.
Und das hier könnte auswählen. Also ich gehe davon aus,
das ist echt. Bei dem hier, keine Ahnung.
Aber bei dem hier,
das wird schon gut passen.
Aber ansonsten gibt's halt nix, ne?
Wir warten mal morgen ab.
Du nutzt KeyPass als Passwortmanager,
oder? Was benutzt du?
Gar nichts.
Ich synch das nur zwischen meinen Desktoprechnern.
Ich hab ja hier den Streamingrechner und den
Vorschaurechner.
Synch ich das über
der Nextcloud. Aber ich mag
Nextcloud nicht, sag ich gleich dabei.
Sag ich da jedes Mal, wenn es um das Thema
Nextcloud geht.
Und ich synch es nicht
auf Mobile Geräte oder sonst was.
Das ist dem Menu, die
Quatsch, was ich das hier
brauchste. Wenn du Programme
starten willst und Zwischenablage
machen willst, mancher auch wie ich. Das hier.
Okay, die Frage, die Frage
kommt öfters. Deswegen
kann ich jetzt schon mal ein Video
leaken, weil wir hier gerade beim
Leaken sind. Wenn Battlefield geleakt wird,
leak ich jetzt einfach mal neue Videos.
Und zwar die Frage
kommt so oft, dass
ich demnächst ein Video mache, also dass wir
zusammen ein Video machen werden.
Und zwar mit ihm.
Zusammen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand
seinen Channel kennt.
Aber er ist ja auch schon mittlerweile relativ
groß. Also ich denke mal, die meisten, die sich
für solche Themen interessieren, haben ihn vielleicht
schon mal gesehen.
Wir machen demnächst ein Video Top 5
Programmiersprachen für
Einsteiger.
Es wird darauf rauslaufen, dass wir
also an Programmiersprachen
werden wir wohl nehmen.
Python, Javascript,
Go, C Sharp.
Und jetzt ratet mal, was ist
die fünfte Sprache?
C++, ja ne C.
Und das ergibt in dem Fall
auch Sinn.
Weil
er will das Thema Aduinos
und Microcontroller ansprechen.
Und da passt das
schon, auch wenn ich C++...
Ich habe aber schon gesagt, also
ich möchte
den Einwand bringen, dass ich C++ nicht mag
in dem Video noch.
Jetzt an soweit ist.
Ja, also genau.
Und mit die fünf Sprachen werden wir uns
jeder kurz auslassen.
Oder mal gucken, wie wir das aufteilen.
Also wir wissen schon, wie wir das aufteilen.
Aber wir wissen noch nicht so genau, wer wieviel
was zu dem
Themen des anderen sagen will.
Mal gucken, ob wir das hochladen.
Jetzt, die nächsten Tage, wenn Battlefield kommt,
kommt erstmal ein Battlefield Video und dann mache ich
das.
Aber das gibt es dann imnächst.
Jetzt habe ich auch was geleakt.
So.
Ja.
Aber weißt du was, also allgemein
gesprochen dazu.
Das Beste ist, wenn du eine Idee hast,
was du machen willst. Also wenn du sagst,
also wie kommt es darauf,
dass du anfangen willst zu programmieren? Hast du irgendwas schon
im Kopf, wo du sagst, hey,
das würde ich gerne machen?
Wenn ja, dann braucht man irgendwie
eine Sprachetechnologie, die sich gut dafür eignet
und dann einfach anfangen.
Am besten ist natürlich
parallel Tutorials gucken,
beziehungsweise falls es Bücher gibt, auch
PDFs. Es ist auch sinnvoll.
Es ist einfach oftmals strukturierter
von Anfang bis ganz gutes
Level als irgendwie YouTube
Tutorials gucken.
Ist Go nicht die Konkurrenz
von C und C? Nee, nicht wirklich.
Every Programming Tutorial, das
kenne ich. Also wenn du
schon eine Idee hast, was du machen willst, kannst du ja mal
in den Chat schreiben, aber
daran hängt es halt ein bisschen ab. Und wenn du noch gar
keine Idee hast und einfach nur
ein bisschen
da dir das angucken
willst, dann kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt plus
JavaScript
ans Herz legen, nimm den Browser
und bastel ein bisschen mit JavaScript
rum, CSS, HTML.
Dann siehst du nämlich auch gleich, was passiert.
Wie ist es, wenn es nicht
wirklich aushält?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Wir haben bei manchen Besprechungen die
Webcam an, aber ich hab sie
bei den meisten aus, also
die meisten haben sie bei den meisten, also bei
den normalen Besprechungen haben wir die Webcam aus.
Also wenn ich jetzt jemand anrufe, haben wir
in der Regel die Webcam nicht an.
Das geht ja auch in Teams gar nicht richtig.
Wenn du die Webcam am zweiten Rechner hast. Das geht ja nur, wenn du in der Konferenz bist.
Dann haben wir die aus. Aber sag mal, in der Teamrunde haben wir die
meistens, zumindest mal kurz am Anfang zum Winken, andernach mach ich meistens wieder aus.
So, ich guck mal kurz, ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab.
Ich glaube, die machen damit noch zu viel Geld. Was? Fortnite Stream? Warum soll ich ein Fortnite Stream machen?
Ich will nie ein Fortnite Stream machen oder auch kein Fortran Stream.
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe gar nichts übersehen.
Was? Hallo? Jetzt wird es aber hier. Ah, hier, Moment, sage ich gleich was zu.
Also, das habe ich überhaupt nicht gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, Javascript und dazu CSS,
HTML. Willst du mit Javascript im Browser ohne CSS, HTML, was machen? Kannste machen, aber du siehst nichts.
Oder QBasic, genau. Also, ich hatte in der Schule programmiert als Fach,
jedoch muss ich sagen, dass ich gar keinen Spaß habe. Ja, das liegt aber wahrscheinlich an der Schule.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal so. Oftmals war der Unterricht so, dass der Lehrer uns
ein Skript gezeigt hat, es erklärt hat und aus dem Raum gegangen ist. Ja, das ist für ein Arsch.
Das ist natürlich sinnlos. Na, wenn du Webseiten erstellen willst, dann bleibt ja nichts anderes
übrig außer JavaScript, CSS, HTML. Und ich finde, persönlich ist es auch der beste Einstieg,
weil du direkt siehst, was passiert. Dass der Rollstuhl-Hater wieder am Start.
Was ist der Vorteil von interpretierten Sprachen bzw. was zeichnen sie aus?
Moment, war das heute eine Abschlussprüfung drinne, kann das sein? War heute Abschlussprüfung,
das wurde gefragt. Oder? Also, ich kann dir das sagen. Ich kann dir das sagen für den Fall der
Fall. Also, der Vorteil ist erst mal prinzipiell gar keiner. Also, das Sprach, das Feature-Set einer
Sprache hat jetzt erst mal nicht primär damit was zu tun, ob sie interpretiert ist oder kompiliert
wird. Man muss sagen, der Übergang ist heutzutage auch fließend. Also, mein, klar, du hast
natürlich so Sachen auf der einen Seite, wie nennen wir mal irgendwie Rust oder C. Und auf der
anderen Sachen so Dinge wie, ja, was gibt es denn, was noch rein interpretiert ist? Was gibt es denn,
was noch rein interpretiert ist, was nicht irgendwelche Optimierungssachen macht? Nee,
JavaScript auch nicht. JavaScript schon lange nicht mehr. Java erst recht nicht. Was ist
denn noch wirklich rein interpretiert? Perl, Perl vielleicht. Bash, Bash, genau, Bash ist ein
gutes Beispiel. Also, mein, prinzipiell wird man schon sagen, so was wie Python und Ruby,
aber selbst da ist das nicht mehr so. Die versuchen auch da schon Optimierung zu machen.
Und JavaScript ist schon lange nicht mehr interpretiert in dem klassischen Sinn, so
Zeile für Zeile, wie das früher war. Es gibt da richtig gute Konferenzvorträge von den V8
Leuten. V8 ist die JavaScript Engine von Chrome. Die machen da total abgedrehtes Zeugs für.
Ja, also, wie gesagt, der Übergang ist fließend, ja. Überleg grad, was ist denn ein Vorteil,
wenn man jetzt mal unabhängig von Sprachen und die das können, was könnte ein Vorteil sein von
einer interpretierten Sprache, dass sie schneller startet vielleicht oder, dass du schneller,
theoretisch schneller entwickeln kannst, mit direkt Programmcode ändern, ausführen. Was ist
da, was ist da groß, was ist da größter Vorteil? Wie gesagt, zumal der Übergang eh fließend ist
mittlerweile. Ist da so wirklich was einfacher portierbar, würde ich auch gar nicht unbedingt
sagen. Das Kompilieren kann ich fehlschlagen, ja, das stimmt. Kannst einen Runtime-Fehler
kriegen. Was ist denn so da wirklich groß? Das startet schneller. Das ist eigentlich was mir
einfällt. Chat, fällt euch noch irgendwas ein? Was ist der große Vorteil von interpretierten
Sprachen? Startzeit? Tja, mir fällt echt nichts bei. Code veränderbar während der Runtime? Ja,
theoretisch schon praktisch. Ja, du hast recht, theoretisch schon praktisch, aber halt auch nicht,
weil die das auch im Vorfeld alles parsen und cashen und optimieren. Wie gesagt,
der Übergang ist fließend mittlerweile. Also ich würde die Wahl einer Programmiersprache definitiv
nicht davon abhängig machen, ob sie in irgendeiner Art interpretiert, kompiliert,
sonst was ist. Der Ventress ist am Start, moin, oder? Ja, moin. Ach, moin, ist gut, moin geht
eigentlich immer. Bin aber auch gleich weg übrigens in 10 Minuten. So, bin ich wieder
ziemlich hinten dran. Das neue CSGO Update hat ein Abo für Statistiken für. Ernsthaft? Ja,
gut. Der muss schon gucken, woran bleibt. Was würdest du für eine Cloud empfehlen? Ich mag
Next Cloud nicht. Kann ich dir nichts empfehlen? Ich hab Next Cloud, aber ich mag Next Cloud nicht.
Ja, das ist auch das Einzige, wie gesagt, was mir einfällt. How to get, ok. Ich hoffe,
es ist kein Monka Toss Bild. Ist das Bill Dates? Ja, Lull, Verhaltnis Lull. Kenn ich nicht.
Ne, es gibt im Browser nur JavaScript, wenn du Webseiten machen willst. Es gibt in so gut
wie jeder Programmiersprache Backend Web Server Implementierungen und Web Frameworks
Backend technisch. Aber im Browser, da gibt es nur JavaScript und ihr müsst mir jetzt nicht mit
WebAssembly kommen, damit kannst du noch keine Seiten gescheit. Ich wusste, dass der erste
WebAssembly ankommt. Lull, ich muss predicten, Leute. Chat, ihr seid zu durchschaubar manchmal.
Damit kannst du aber noch keine Seiten richtig manipulieren. Ja, heute war Abschlussprüfung
bei ganz vielen. Dass du theoretische Sachen lernst. Ja, dass du zum Beispiel weißt, wie man
ein Binary Tree invertet. Das weiß jemand, der eine Fachinformatik Ausbildung gemacht hat,
nicht, dass du Ahnung von Mathe-Kundlagen hast. Oder was heißt Grundlagen? Informatik hat ja
schon zum größten Teil Mathe. Rust Stream, das könnten wir tatsächlich mal machen,
habe schon einiges mal mitgemacht. Nein, das ist tagesaktuell, je nachdem, wie aktuell die
Firmware ist von den China-Chinesen. Aber du kannst im Zweifelfall sie einfach bei Amazon
wieder zurückschicken. Oh, darf ich das sagen als Twitch-Partner? Ich weiß nicht. Der Gaben
muss gucken, woran er bleibt. Die V8, Leute. Ja, also die JavaScript-Editor von Chrome ist
sicherlich damit auch für den Electron-Siegeszug und sowas verantwortlich. Aber wisst ihr,
wovon ich hauptsächlich auch ausgehe, warum Electron so erfolgreich ist. Also nicht nur,
weil eben Web-Anwendungen überall laufen und sonst wo. Das hat alles seinen Grund und es
hätte sich auch definitiv so durchgesetzt. Aber ein ganz entscheidender Faktor meiner Meinung nach
ist, dass Microsoft es 20 Jahre lang nicht hinbekommen hat, na gut 20 Jahre ist übertrieben,
15 Jahre nicht hinbekommen hat, ein ordentliches Desktop-UI-Framework zu machen. Meinetwegen auch
Windows Only. Es gab Windows Forms, das war zu seiner Zeit okay. Es gab WPF, das war zu seiner
Zeit auch okay, aber hatte auch schon richtig Probleme mit der Integration beispielsweise von
DirectX Geschichten und selbstgerenderten Geschichten. Ging alles irgendwie, war nicht schön. Ist aber
schon seit zehn Jahren hoffnungslos veraltet. Sie ist ja zum Beispiel daran, dass WPF und Windows
Forms, Controls keine Emojis anzeigen können. Da weißt du schon mal outdated. Alles was heutzutage
unter Windows keine grafischen, das meine ich ernst jetzt, wirklich ernst. Alles was heutzutage
unter Windows keine grafischen Emojis anzeigen lassen kann, ist auf outdated Frameworks aufgesetzt
und das ist erstaunlich viel. Dazu kommt, dass das Font-Rendering von Anfang an im WPF massiv
kacke war. Mittlerweile ist glaube ich besser, aber auch naja. So und die haben es nicht geschafft,
15 Jahre lang ein ordentliches UI-Framework rauszubringen für Windows und irgendwann kam
sie dann auf die Idee, quasi Microsoft hat sich dann gesagt und hat UWP gemacht und spätestens
da sind eh alle weggerannt. Und jetzt wollen sie wieder zurück davon und kriegen es nicht
gebacken. WinUI 3 ist eine gute Idee. Das hier war ja die Idee von Microsoft, wer das nicht
kennt. Microsoft hat ja die Idee, mit diesem Projekt hier, das was sie UWP Only gebaut
haben, von UWP zu trennen. Also sprich das normale Desktop-Anwendung auf die UI-Technologie
von UWP zugreifen können. Eigentlich eine gute Idee, weil ich muss sagen, auch wenn
der Calculator abgrundtief kacke aussieht, die unterliegende UI-Technologie ist eigentlich
nicht schlecht. Das hat ein paar ganz coole Geschichten zum Beispiel, ich glaube es ist
euch noch nie aufgefallen, dass das Ding beispielsweise Transparenz kann. Und das ist nicht einfache
Transparenz, was man im Hintergrund hier sieht. Also das ist nicht einfach nur leicht transparent,
dass man ein bisschen was sieht. Nein, die haben eine ganz spezielle Logik, dass der
Hintergrund genommen wird und so, also dass man spezielle Transparenz macht, dass es
so aussieht, als würde der Hintergrund durchschimmern, ohne dass wirklich der Hintergrund durchschimmern,
sodass der Kontrast immer gegeben ist von den Anwendungen. Also die haben sich da schon
viele Gedanken zu gemacht bei ihren UI-Geschichten, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Ne, es ist
auch kein einfacher Blur-Effekt. Sie passen das wirklich an, wenn der Kontrast zu gering
wird, wird es geändert, also das ist wirklich nicht doof. Leider haben sie es verkackt und
haben gesagt, ja okay, wir wollten es eigentlich für normale Windows-Anwendungen rausbringen,
aber wir machen das erst mit der nächsten Version. So, das heißt jetzt ist es im Prinzip
Todgeburt. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem, hat auch einer hier in GitHub-Issue geschrieben,
in welchem Parallel-Universum Microsoft lebt, dass die echter Meinung sind, dass auch 2021
es eine gute Idee ist, wenn man diesen Packaged-UVP-Gramm beibehält und nicht einfach steht, normale
Windows-Anwendung support. Ich verstehe es nicht. Das größte Problem, was ich daran
sehe, ist zum Beispiel, wenn du so eine Anwendung erstellen willst mit diesem Framework, selbst
wenn es eine ganz kleine Furz-Anwendung ist, die einfach nur ein Fenster anzeigt, in dem
Test steht, du brauchst ein gültiges Code-Signing-Zertifikat und jemand, der GitHub-Open-Source-Anwendungen
machen will oder irgendwas oder einfach nur mal damit anfangen will, man irgendwie braucht
seinen Einstieg dafür. Der kauft sich doch kein 350 Euro, 400 Euro im Jahr Code-Signing-Zertifikat,
nur dass du dann solche Anwendungen machen darfst. Ist doch hängen geblieben. Also Microsoft
lebt, was UI-Sachen angeht, komplett in einer eigenen Welt und ich weiß nicht, was die machen.
Aber es ist ja auch kein Wunder. Ich meine, man muss sich nur das hier angucken. Das genau
in dieser UI-Welt lebt Microsoft halt. TypeScript wird dann auch als, nee, Deno ist V8. Also,
da ist die Chrome-Java-Script-Engine drunter unter Deno. Das ist auch nur interpretiert
beim ersten Durchlauf und dort, wo er nichts optimieren kann. So richtige UI-Desktop-Geschichten
sind schon schwierig. Ich mein, Apple kriegt's hin. Microsoft hat das prinzipiell mit Windows
Forms auch mal hinbekommen und teilweise WPF. Qt kriegt das auch ganz gut hin. Aber Crossplatform
ist halt das Schwierige, ja. Aber Windows Only sollte man noch hinkriegen als Betriebssystem-Hersteller.
Flutter zeigt auch, dass das vom Ansatz her gut funktionieren könnte. Leider ist das
noch nicht ganz ausgereift auf dem Desktop. Ja gut, gegen Runtime-Errors machst du halt
bei beidem nix. Runtime-Errors kannst du bei beidem bekommen. Also, egal ob interpretiert
oder kompiliert, Runtime-Errors kannst du bei beidem haben. Die Sache ist nur die, dass
du halt viele potenzielle Fehler, wenn's ne typisierte Sprache ist, im Vorfeld schon
abfangen kannst. Das ist also unabhängig davon, ob das interpretiert ist, kompiliert,
ist halt die Frage. Ist das typisiert, wird das vorher gecheckt? Wenn ja, kriegt man bestimmt
viele Dinge vorher schon abgefangen. Deswegen ist ja TypeScript auch so beliebt. TypeScript
ist eigentlich ne richtig Poggers-Geschichte. Man spart sich total viel sinnloses ausprobieren,
weil man was falsch getippt hat. Ja, stimmt, ich schlafe gleich. Ja. Wieso, was hab ich
gesagt? Übrigens Leute, Details sag ich euch nicht, aber ich hab mit Hetzner die Woche
nochmal geschrieben. Das ist bei ihnen wohl auch gut gelaufen, der Test mit dem Video.
Also, das heißt, der Chat war wieder massive cute und hat auch ordentlich Hetzner-Codes
eingelöst. Lief ganz gut. Jetzt guck ich mal, dass wir da irgendwie so ein monatliches
Paket machen über alles von Twitter bis Discord, YouTube, Twitch. Dass wir da irgendwie was
bauen, was jetzt nicht so aufdringlich ist, dass es jetzt quasi euch erschlägt. Einfach
nur, dass das überall schön integriert ist und dann machen wir da irgendwie so ein bisschen
Festpreis oder so und schauen wir mal. Mal gucken, was da rauskommt. Na, eine Cloud-Hostel,
ja gut, Nextcloud hat ja mit Cloud auch erstmal nix zu tun. Nextcloud ist eine File-Zug-Software
mit Kalender. Erstmal ein paar Plugins dabei. Warum das Ding Cloud heißt? Ja, wahrscheinlich
weil es viele Funktionen hat von Software, die es ansonsten halt in der Cloud gibt. Nextcloud
ist die stinknormale PHP-Anwendung, was ja mit Cloud nichts zu tun hat. Das heißt halt
so. Too predictable. Ja, ich hab den Chat durchschaut wieder. Ja, es geht nur für Neukunden,
was jetzt nicht heißt, dass ihr euch nicht neu... Nein, nein, das darf man nicht. Kann
man das öffnen? Lilux-Memes. Come and get it. Ah, halbes Lull, halbes Lull. Was ist
mit Razor, Blazer, By-C-Sharp? Ist das auch JavaScript? Nee, nicht direkt. Blazer ist
entweder Server-Side, dann ist es JavaScript, dann ist es Signal-R und JavaScript im Frontend,
nur dass es versteckt wird von dir. Oder es ist Blazer-Client-Side, dann ist es eine
komplette.NET-Runtime in WebAssembly, die dazu führt, dass der Download, dass du erstmal
8 MB downloaden musst, dass die Webseite überhaupt anfängt zu laden. Und selbst dann brauchst
du noch JavaScript, wenn du die Webseite manipulieren willst. Es sei denn, du verwendest nur eingebaute
Funktionen. Die machen das unter der Haupe auch mit JavaScript, nur dass du nichts davon
mitbekommst. Aber sobald du irgendwie was custom-mäßig machen möchtest, was mit der
Webseite interagiert, also mit dem, was der User sieht, dann ist das auch JavaScript,
ja. Du kannst aktuell mit WebAssembly, soweit ich weiß, Chat, vielleicht wisst ihr da mehr,
du kannst aktuell mit WebAssembly keinerlei Webseiten-Dom-Manipulation machen. Du musst
das immer über JavaScript callen. Also das heißt, du hast im Prinzip keine andere Wahl
als JavaScript zu machen. Die China-Chinesen oder alternativ auch die chinesischen China-Chinesen,
ja. Ich finde Qt gut, das Problem ist, dass es T++ ist. Flutter fand ich auch nice, was
wir da letztens gesehen haben im Stream. Der Chain, Leute, will wieder time-outet werden,
glaube ich, ja. So, da ist er weg. Wenn er time-outet werden will. I can't wait. Brings
dem Chain-Lore haben wir hier ein paar von den coolen Immorts zu verdanken. Um nicht
zu sagen alle. Wobleave mache ich gleich, ja. Mein Desktop, also ich finde, mein Desktop
ist der ergonomischste Desktop überhaupt. Der Chat sagt, der immer mal finde da drauf
nichts, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es so, dass es alles einer wohl definierten inneren Ordnung
folgt auf dem Desktop. Wenn ihr mir was sagt, ich finde es sofort. Easy. Ich habe keine
Ahnung, da musste die Discord-Bot-Api-Doku lesen. Ja, finde ich übrigens auch. Auch von
der Optik her. Jetzt mal, Chat, Frage an euch. Was findet ihr besser? Optisch. Ich rede nicht
von rein optisch. Das oder das? Meiner Meinung nach sieht das neue aus wie eine Webseite,
die jemand in 5 Minuten zusammengeschissen hat. Und das hier sieht nach einem normalen
UI aus, ja. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist. Ah, das habe ich ja nie gemacht. Kann
man aber gut vorstellen. Ja, hier. Exzellent Werbung. Kenn ich nicht. Kann man auch machen,
dann hast du aber cross-platformmäßig auch die Probleme, wie du die Anwendung verpacken
willst, verteilen willst. Wo es bei Python aufhört und Qt ist die Kombination, wenn
du beispielsweise irgendwelche Erweiterungen machen willst. Wobei ich mir da nicht sicher
bin, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe Python Qt nie zusammen verwendet. Wenn du
zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal das standardmäßige Text-Editor-Control, wenn du das erweitern
willst zu was kann, dann kommst du glaube ich an C++ nicht vorbei. Bin ich mir aber
nicht sicher. Ansonsten ist das auch auf jeden Fall eine Option und das kann man machen.
Bild von meiner Katze auf dem Desktop, das ist einfach. Easy. Schneller als ihr das gefunden
werdet wahrscheinlich. Gebt es zu. Ich kenne mich auf meinem Desktop aus. Früher war alles
besser. Ja, also zu QBasic Zeiten ja. Übrigens, Chat, Twitter, wer von euch weiß noch, was
das hier ist? Die meisten werden es wahrscheinlich wissen. 56k Modem, das ist nicht nur irgendein
56k Modem. Guck mal Twitter Trends. Was trendet denn? Bestimmt irgendwas wurscht mich wieder
aus. Ausgangssperren trendet, Sebastian trendet, Five senses for love, irgendwelche Fußballgeschichten,
Fliegenpilz trendet, Whatsapp trendet. Ihr wisst, ich lese keine Twitter Trends. Twitter Trends
triggern mich immer. Paintschamp, Twitter Trends. Könnte man machen. Also wie gesagt, eigentlich
wollte ich ein Video machen, war ich dann wahrscheinlich morgen, wenn morgen der Battlefield Trailer
nicht droppt, weil jetzt gerade sage ich jetzt noch kurz, weil ich hier was von der Katz geschrieben
habe. Ich wollte mal ein Video zu machen, zu haustieren. Ich weiß ja nichts mit Gaming
oder sonst IT zu tun, weil ich das doofe Gefühl habe, dass viele Leute jetzt daheim
sitzen und sich einsam fühlen, auch wegen Corona und sich dann überlegen, ich hole
mir jetzt einen Hund oder ich hole mir eine Katze und sich keine Gedanken darüber machen,
was ist, wenn sie wieder auf die Arbeit gehen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, sobald die Leute
wieder auf die Arbeit gehen, das erste was passiert ist, Mist, Katze ist ja doch viel
anstrengender, als ich mir das gedacht habe, ab ins Tierheim. So und die Tierheime werden
platzen, wenn Corona wieder vorbei ist. Und gerade auch wenn ich lese, dass die Leute
sich im Internet irgendwelche Hunde kaufen oder sowas. Ich meine unsere Tierheime sind
voll, du musst nicht ins Internet gehen, um dir erst einen Hund zu kaufen. Ja, ich weiß
viele sagen, ich will aber einen kleinen Hund und dann muss es auch genau die richtige
Rasse sein und bla und sonst was. Ich, das kann ich nicht verstehen, gerade wenn man dann
bei irgendwelchen komischen Seiten was kauft. Ich meine, wer ist so bescheuert und geht zu
Ebay. Im Prinzip unterstützt man ja das Business damit ja noch, die da illegale Machenschaften
treiben. So und ich würde immer vorziehen, was aus dem Tierheim zu holen und worauf ich
eigentlich raus will in dem Video ist, die Leute sollen sich nicht nur um jetzt Gedanken
machen, also so nach dem Motto, jetzt ist wenig los bei mir daheim, ich fühle mich einsam,
ich hole mir eine Katze, ich hole mir einen Hund oder ich hole mir irgendwas. Sondern
die Leute sollen sich Gedanken machen, dass das eigentlich eine Investition, das ist das
Investition ist das falsche Wort, dass das eigentlich eine, wie bezeichnen wir das, Verbindung,
nee Verantwortung, Verantwortung ist für im Zweifelsfall auch mal 20 Jahre. Also wenn
du dir heute eine Katze holst, wahrgenommen du holst dir eine recht junge Katze, die gibt
es ja auch im Tierheim welche, die irgendwie ein halbes Jahr alt sind, Jahr alt sind. So
und du holst dir jetzt eine Katze, die kann heute ohne Probleme 20 Jahre werden oder teilweise
noch älter. Das heißt, du musst das mit einkalkulieren, du musst dir da Gedanken darüber
machen und sagen, okay, ich weiß, dass ich mich die nächsten 20 Jahre um die Katze kümmern
muss. So und das muss den Leuten klar sein, das hat keinen Sinn sich da aus so einem Impuls
raus ein Haustier zu holen, das macht einen vielleicht mal kurzzeitig happy, weil man nicht
mal allein daheim ist, aber für die Katze ist das auf jeden Fall nichts tolles, wenn
die danach einem halben Jahr gerade wo sie sich eingewöhnt hat wieder ins Tierheim geschmissen
wird. Also eines der blödesten Sachen, die ich da mitbekommen habe, ist da in dem Tierheim,
wo ich gewesen bin, wo ich die letzten zwei Katzen geholt habe. Also die aktuelle, die
davor und die erste Katze FPS, die ihr kennt, die hatte ich ja vom Nachbar, also die hat
ja beim Nachbar gewohnt und die wohnen ja da nicht mehr und so zumindest, also jetzt,
also meine aktuelle ist ja das hier und die davor, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich ein Bild
hab, ist das hier. Die war leider krank, deswegen, die war auch schon alt und krank, das wusste
ich vorher nicht, aber gut, konnte ich auch nichts machen. Zumindest ging es bei mir gut
dann soweit und jetzt habe ich halt die hier und davor hatte ich ja, die kennt ihr ja alle
noch aus den Videos glaube ich, davor hatten wir die hier. So und also eine richtig blöde
Sache, die ich da mitbekommen habe, ist folgendes, als ich hier, die hieß halt Barbie, ja ich
hab mir den Namen nicht ausgedacht, ich finde es immer noch bis heute, Massive Pains Champic,
dass man eine Katze Barbie nennt, aber ok, vor allem die war ultra fett, die war mega
fett die Katze, die sah absolut nicht aus wie Barbie, die sah so dick aus. Sieht dein
Desktop auf dem Arbeitsrechner auch so aus? Ne, ich hab keinen Desktop auf dem Arbeitsrechner,
ich hab i3, da hat kein Desktop. So zumindest, als ich hier im Tierheim war und Barbie geholt
hab, da hab ich mitbekommen, dass, also ich hab sie besucht, ich hab sie besucht und da
kommst du ja, in dem Raum sind ja noch total viele andere Katzen drinnen. Und in dem Tierheim
waren die halt alle, waren halt jede Katze in so einem eigenen Käfig, auch relativ groß
und so, da kannst du nix sagen und die haben auch so ein Freilaufzimmer gehabt und so alles
gut. Zumindest war ich da, hab sie besucht, muss man ein bisschen kennenlernen und da
hab ich gesehen, dass so ein älteres Ehepaar war da und die haben auch zwei Katzen gerade
abgeholt. So und da bin ich dann zwei oder drei Wochen später wieder hin und dann haben
wir Barbie abgeholt aus dem Tierheim und da hab ich gesehen, die zwei Katzen waren auf
einmal wieder da, wo ich vor zwei Wochen dabei war, wo die abgeholt wurden. Da hab ich mal
die Pflegerin da gefragt, hab ich gesagt, hä, wo kommen die denn auf einmal wieder her
und da meinte die so, ja, die Leute haben die mit heim genommen und haben sich dann
gewundert, dass die Katze nur unterm Sofa sitzt und die andere Katze hat irgendwie noch
einen Blumentopf umgeschmissen und da hätten sie die Katzen wieder zurückgebracht. Ich
mein, machen die Leute sich keine Gedanken? Wie bescheuert, ja genau, wie bescheuert kann
es richtig pepega, ich mein, wie bescheuert kannst du eigentlich sein? Zumal das ja auch
nicht die Schuld von der Katze ist, das ist doch vollkommen normal. Also wenn du, außer
bei Chico, bei Chico hat er das nicht, die hat am ersten Tag schon auf dem Schrank gelegt,
ja. Das ist normal, dass wenn du die rauslässt, die erstmal wo neu sind, dann verstecken
die sich erstmal. Die kommen dann an der Zeit auch wieder raus, das ist vollkommen normal.
Verstecken sie erstmal und wenn dann ein bisschen Action ist und mal was runterfällt, dann ist
das erste Mal nicht unbedingt Schuld von der Katze, sondern ich würde sagen, hey, ok,
daraus könnte man jetzt ja lernen und das Zeug nicht mehr dahinstellen. Weil, die muss
ja ein bisschen rumrennen können. Ich mein, du hast Katzen, die machen das absichtlich,
ja. Chico schmeißt auch manchmal Sachen runter. Chico schmeißt auch manchmal Sachen
runter, aber absichtlich. So nach dem Motto, ach guck mal, da liegt ja was an der Kante,
ich geh da mal hin und schmeiß das runter. Da kriegt sie dann auch immer ein bisschen
Anschiss und das merkt die auch. Die schmeißt das runter und sitzt dann irgendwo ganz unauffällig
da und leckt sich ab. So, was war, was war? Und wenn ich es dann sehe, wenn ich es dann
sehe und es liegt auf der Erde, das weiß die dann, dann guck ich, Chico, was ist das?
Was hast du dir getrieben, Chico? Dann guckt sie dann immer ganz furchtbar unauffällig,
die weiß das schon, dass sie das nicht runter schmeißen soll, ja. Wieso hast du eigentlich
zwei Verknüpfungen zu Firefox, das hat keinerlei Sinn, das hat sich Firefox selbst installiert.
Katz FPS 8.0 den Puma ärgern, ja wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich. Meine Katz hat ja auch, die
hat zwei Katzenbrunnen oben und unten. Hinten in ihrem Katzenzimmer noch mal so ein Trinkknopf,
aber jedes Mal, wenn ich am Bad vorbei laufe und sie ist in der Nähe, rennt sie an mir
vorbei ins Bad und springt aufs Waschbecken und da muss ich erstmal das Waschbecken anmachen.
Und dann wird dann, dann wird dann tröpfchenweise aus dem Waschbecken, aus dem Wasserhahn getrunken.
Aber das mögen Katzen, Katzen mögen so fließendes Wasser. Versuch mal den Venice Unleashed Client
auf dem Desktop zu finden, ist gar kein Problem, das hier unten. Können wir gerade mal kurz
gucken wie viele Venice Unleashed Server voll sind. Schauen wir mal. Keine, ich weiß. Oh
nein, neun von 64, easy. Euro Knallers. Ah, die haben es verkackt. Warum sind die Emojis
nicht alle in einem Ordner? Ordner ist für Noobs. Kein richtiger Hacker mein verwendet
Ordner. So Leute, ich, wie kannst du da durchblicken? Tja, ich kann das halt, ich hab da halt den
Durchblick, ja. Äh, was hast du für einen Katzenbrunnen, so einen mit Strahl? Äh, das
ist kein einzelner Strahl, das ist so ein, das geht so in eine unterschiedliche Richtung.
Ah, nochmal, ich kann dir zeigen, was ich für einen Katzenbrunnen hab. Ich hab ja zwei
verschiedene. Eigentlich hab ich sogar drei verschiedene, wobei ich nur noch zwei Stück,
sowas hab ich. Sowas hab ich. Davor hatte ich, äh, davor hatte ich den da. Also ich
hab zwei Stück, zwei Stück davon in der Richtung, das ist nicht exakt, die aber so ähnlich
sind die, ja. Zwei Stück davon und davor hatte ich, davor hatte ich so einen, der ist eigentlich
viel besser gewesen. Nur, dass Chico zu kurzen Hals hat, da raus zu trinken, die schafft's
nicht, die kriegt's nicht gebacken, da raus zu trinken. Zu dick und zu kurzer Hals, keine
Ahnung. Ja, also Leute, wir sehen uns, macht's gut, bis dann, CEO. Ich guck auf der Frasier,
wenn ihr spielt, dann, äh, alles klar. Okay, macht's gut, bis dann, CEO.